>> BEING A SUPERMODEL
HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE MOST AMAZING EXPERIENCES
OF MY LIFE.
I'VE TRAVELED
ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND MODELED
THE HOTTEST FASHION DESIGNS.
I DECIDED TO PASS THE TORCH
AND INTRODUCE SOME
OF THE FRESHEST
AND MOST VERSATILE BEAUTIES
TO THE INDUSTRY I LOVE...
>> JUST GIVE ME
SOMETHING DRAMATIC.
OVERDO IT.
>> AND BELIEVE ME,
I KNOW A TOP MODEL
WHEN I SEE ONE.
OUR FINALISTS
HAVE BLASTED INTO SUCCESS
ON THE RUNWAY,
IN MAGAZINES,
ON TELEVISION
AND IN EVERY FASHION CAPITAL
ON THE GLOBE.
THIS SEASON,
JUST 33 GIRLS WERE SELECTED
FROM THOUSANDS OF HOPEFULS...
>> YEE-HAW!
>> AND OUR EXPERTS
WILL BE TOUGHER THAN EVER.
>> YOU NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SLINKY-INK DOWN THE RUNWAY.
>> PUT YOUR ARM UP LIKE THAT.
PUT YOUR OTHER ARM UP, TOO,
AND JUST HAVE
A LITTLE SMALL MOMENT.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO USE
WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
>> IF I HONESTLY HAD TO PUBLISH
THIS PICTURE, I WOULD CROP YOU
RIGHT OUT OF IT.
>> IN JUST 12 WEEKS,
ONE OF THESE GIRLS WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
>> IT'S CRAZY.
I AM, LIKE, SO EXCITED.
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE.
IT'S, LIKE, OPPORTUNITY
OF A LIFETIME,
AND SOMETIMES I STILL THINK
IT'S LIKE A DREAM.
>> THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE
THAT I'M HERE.
I'M FROM THIS REALLY,
REALLY SMALL TOWN.
IT'S ONLY 180 PEOPLE.
NOBODY WANTS IT MORE THAN ME,
SO NOBODY'S GONNA GET IT.
>> I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT BEING HERE,
BUT IN ANOTHER ASPECT,
I'M KINDA SAD,
BECAUSE MY KIDS ARE AT HOME
SICK WITH THE FLU,
AND NOT ONLY IS MOMMY NOT THERE,
BUT DADDY'S NOT THERE, EITHER.
HE'S IN IRAQ.
♪♪♪
>> WELCOME, WELCOME.
>> (screaming)
>> BOOM!
MISS J. IS RIGHT THERE
IN FRONT OF ME,
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
"HOLY COW!
SHE'S SO--HE--WHATEVER--
IS SO TALL!"
>> WELCOME TO ANTM FLIGHT 701.
I AM YOUR FLIGHT ATTENDANT
TODAY, MISS J.
IN THIS BUSINESS,
YOU HAVE TO BE UP AND READY
FOR ANYTHING.
TODAY YOU WILL BE GOING
TO YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
(record needle scratches)
>> PHOTO SHOOT ALREADY?
I'M LIKE, "WAIT, LET ME,
YOU KNOW, FRESHEN UP
AND LOOK ALL CUTE AND STUFF."
>> GRAB YOUR BAGS AND FOLLOW ME.
♪♪♪
>> FOLLOW ME, LADIES.
SO, GIRLS, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT,
WHICH IS USUALLY WHAT HAPPENS--
GETTING OFF OF A PLANE,
GOING STRAIGHT TO LOCATION.
YOU ARE GONNA HAVE TO GIVE ME
TEN INCREDIBLE POSES.
>> HOW'S IT GOIN'?
STAY ON THE BLUE, PLEASE.
>> WE'RE JUST GONNA DO
TEN SHOTS.
ALL RIGHT. WORK IT OUT, GIRL.
GORGEOUS.
>> ♪ COME ON ♪
>> I'VE NEVER DONE ANY KIND
OF PROFESSIONAL MODELING EVER.
>> TURN.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THEY'RE JUST SHOVING ME
IN FRONT OF THIS CAMERA
AND TAKIN' PICTURES OF ME.
>> SOFTEN THE LIPS.
WHO'S NEXT?
GIVE ME A LITTLE PROFILE.
NICE.
>> I'M WATCHIN' THE OTHER GIRLS
TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>> NEXT.
>> THEY JUST SEEM
REALLY NERVOUS,
UNSURE OF THEMSELVES.
I JUST THINK, AT 23,
I JUST HAVE THE CONFIDENCE
THAT I KNOW I WANT TO DO THIS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
THANK YOU.
RELAX.
>> I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
IT WAS INTENSE, AND I WAS
TRYING TO GO OUT THERE
AND JUST SHOW MY STUFF.
>> OKAY, HERE WE GO.
FANTASTIC.
TURN IN A LITTLE.
RIGHT THERE.
PERFECT.
>> I'M REALLY FREE-SPIRITED.
I'M CRAZY.
I DON'T CARE
WHAT PEOPLE THINK OF ME.
I DON'T AT ALL.
I DO A LOT OF THINGS THAT
PEOPLE NORMALLY WOULDN'T DO.
>> YEAH.
JUST WORK IT OUT, GIRL.
THAT'S FIERCE.
I LOVE THAT.
>> I WANT TO, LIKE,
SHOW AMERICA,
"HEY, I CAN DO IT."
I'M GONNA BE
THE FIRST INDIAN CHICK
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> TOO MUCH SMILEY.
GET A LITTLE SERIOUS FOR ME.
BETTER.
NEXT GIRL. HIT IT.
>> SO I WAS JUST LIKE,
YOU KNOW, LIKE, DOING MY FACES,
BEING ALL FIERCE.
I THINK I ROCKED IT. (laughs)
>> THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
>> AW.
>> GOSH!
♪♪♪
>> I HAVE NO IDEA
IF I COUNT AS ONE OR TWO.
I HOPE I COUNT AS ONE AND--
I DON'T KNOW--ONE AND TWO?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> HI. I'M AMANDA.
>> HI. I'M MICHELLE.
>> AND WE'RE BOTH 18.
>> MAN,
THAT TOTALLY KILLS THE JOKE.
>> WHAT WAS THE JOKE?
>> YOU WERE GONNA SAY 18.
I'D BE LIKE, "I'M 18, TOO."
>> OH.
>> STUPID.
>> BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
IT'S, LIKE, ONLY ONE PERSON.
LIKE, I KNOW YOU WOULD BE HAPPY
FOR HER IF SHE WON, BUT...
>> OH, YEAH, I GET
THAT SHE'S STILL COMPETITION,
BUT I STILL...
I KNOW HER BETTER
THAN I KNOW ANY OF YOU,
SO WHY NOT PUT HER IN
OVER ALL OF YOU?
>> THERE'S NOT A LOT OF, LIKE,
TALL, THIN, 6-FEET, TWIN MODELS.
>> AT THIS POINT,
IT'S HARD TO SAY, LIKE,
YOU'RE COMPETING,
BUT YOU ARE.
>> WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN COMPARED
AND COMPETED, LIKE,
ALL OF OUR LIFE,
LIKE, EVERYBODY'S LIKE,
"OH, WHO'S MORE ATHLETIC?
WHO'S SMARTER?" DA-DA-DA-DA.
LIKE, WE ALWAYS GOT
THE WHOLE COMPETITION THING.
WELL, THE IDEAL SITUATION
WOULD BE THAT WE BOTH MAKE IT,
AND THEN I WIN. (chuckles)
♪♪♪
(indistinct conversations)
>> I FEEL ON TOP OF THE WORLD.
>> TO "TOP MODEL"!
>> WHOO!
>> (cheering)
>> THE TWO TWINS OF TWIRL LAND
COME OUT.
>> SWIRL, SWIRL!
>> SWIRL.
>> FOR THE TOP MODEL.
>> I'M RON HARRIS,
AND THIS IS RICHARD HARRIS.
>> WE ARE GONNA TEACH YOU
A TWIRL THAT WE TAUGHT TYRA.
SWIRL.
>> HELL, THEY CAN TEACH ME
HOW TO SWIRL.
I WANNA BE LIKE TYRA.
I'LL BE SWEET.
>> SWIRL, SWIRL, SWIRL.
>> (cheering)
♪♪♪
>> WHOO!
>> (cheering)
>> HEY, EVERYBODY!
>> (screaming)
>> THIS IS MY FAVORITE PART
OF "TOP MODEL."
MEETING THE NEW GIRLS
EVERY SEASON--
THIS IS, LIKE, WHAT I LIVE FOR.
I'M LOOKIN'
AT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU LIKE,
"I SAW YOUR TAPES.
I SAW YOUR TAPES..."
(Southern accent)
"AND YOUR HOMETOWNS,
AND LIKE, 'TYRA,
I WANT TO BE A TOP MODEL.'"
WE'RE GONNA BE DOIN'
SOME SERIOUS INTERVIEWS,
AND I WANT YOU GUYS TO BE REAL,
'CAUSE I CAN SEE STRAIGHT
THROUGH THE FAKE,
LIKE I SAY ALL THE TIME.
YOU JUST BE YOURSELVES,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT GOT YOU HERE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT?
AND IF YOU'RE NERVOUS,
I WANT YOU TO COME IN THAT ROOM
AND SAY, "TYRA, I'M NERVOUS!"
SO I WILL BE SEEING YOU.
SWIRL!
SEE YA LATER!
>> (screaming and cheering)
>> SHE'S ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD.
YOU GUYS,
I-I STILL CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
GOOD MORNING.
HOW IS EVERYBODY?
I'M CHRISTIAN.
I'M FROM
COLUMBIA, SOUTH CAROLINA.
I'M 19.
>> YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE SAD
THAT I'VE RETIRED,
BUT NOW WHAT?
>> BUT NOW I'M READY
TO TAKE YOUR SPOT.
>> CAN YOU GIVE ME
YOUR BEST TYRA BANKS POSE?
>> THERE WAS ONE POSE
THAT SHE DID, AND SHE HAD
HER SHOULDERS ARCHED,
AND SHE HAD HER HEAD UP,
AND IT WAS, LIKE, POUTY.
>> I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT PICTURE
SHE'S TALKIN' ABOUT WITH THE
PURPLE DRESS ON.
>> I KNOW WHAT SHE'S TALKIN'
ABOUT, TOO.
YES, I DO.
>> SHE DID A LITTLE POSE
LIKE THIS WITH HER HAND OVER
HER...
>> OH, YES.
>> OH, THAT ONE, TOO.
>> CAN YOU GIVE ME
THE SIGNATURE, CLASSIC
TYRA BANKS OVER-THE-SHOULDER?
>> I GOT IT?
DID I GET IT?
DID I GET THE POINT?
I FEEL LIKE I JUST NEED
THAT ONE PERSON TO SAY,
"HEY, SHE'S GOT IT,"
THE IT FACTOR, AS THEY CALL IT,
AND I JUST NEED SOMEBODY
TO STEP UP AND GIVE ME A CHANCE.
>> OH, HI!
>> WHOO!
>> AHH!
HELLO.
MY NAME IS CARIDEE.
OH, MY GOSH.
>> J., JUST DO IT FOR ME,
PLEASE.
>> (screaming)
OH, MY GOD.
OH.
>> THERE'S EVEN SOME SPIT
ON HER LEG NOW.
>> (screaming)
>> I GOT IT!
GIVE ME YOUR LEG.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> I JUST HAVE ONE TIP FOR YOU.
DON'T EVER DO THIS EVER AGAIN.
>> I WAS JUST VERY, VERY
NERVOUS,
ESPECIALLY COMING
FROM NORTH DAKOTA.
LIKE, THE MOST FAMOUS PERSON
WE HAVE IN NORTH DAKOTA
IS PAUL BUNYAN,
AND HE'S DEAD.
>> YOU KNOW
WHO YOU REMIND ME OF?
>> WHO?
>> REBECCA ROMIJN.
>> OH, THANK YOU. OH, GOSH.
I'M WEIRD.
I'M KOOKY.
I'M EVERYTHING.
I'M JUST REALLY HIGH-STRUNG
AND JUST OUT THERE.
GOTTA DO IT. OKAY.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> HI. MY NAME'S ANCHAL.
I'M 19--19 YEAR--
19...
I'M SO FREAKIN' NERVOUS.
>> WHY DID YOU
CHOOSE BLUE CONTACTS?
>> I ALWAYS WANTED
DIFFERENT COLOR EYES.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING CULTURALLY IN AMERICA
OR EVEN IN YOUR OWN COUNTRY
THAT IS TELLING YOU
THAT A LIGHTER EYE IS PRETTIER?
>> IN INDIA, THEY DO BELIEVE
THAT LIGHTER SKIN
AND LIGHTER EYES
ARE PRETTIER.
I ACTUALLY WANT TO BEAT THAT,
BE LIKE, "HEY, I'M DARK.
I'M BEAUTIFUL, AND I'M INDIAN.
SO I DON'T HAVE TO BE
LIGHT-SKINNED
OR LIGHT-COLORED EYES
TO BE BEAUTIFUL."
>> WELL, AT LEAST YOU KNOW.
THAT'S THE POWER OF AT LEAST
KNOWING.
LIKE, I KNOW I'M SUCH A SLAVE
WITH THIS DAMN THING ON MY HEAD.
THAT'S THE FIRST STEP.
NEXT STEP IS ME SPORTIN' A 'FRO.
I'LL GET THERE.
>> BUT YOU'VE DONE THAT.
>> I DID...
FOR A HOT SECOND.
>> I WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I WANT TO GET OUT THERE
AND BE LIKE, "HERE I AM."
GO OUT THERE
AND BE WHO YOU ARE.
>> PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THAT IT GOES ACROSS EVERY SINGLE
CULTURE,
THIS WHOLE COLOR THING.
>> I THINK SHE'S GORGEOUS.
>> I AGREE.
>> (cheering)
(laughter)
>> SO YOU SAY, MICHELLE, THAT
YOU ARE THE TOMBOY OF THE TWINS?
>> UH, YEAH, DEFINITELY.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN MORE INTO
SPORTS.
I PLAYED BASKETBALL IN COLLEGE.
>> SO THAT'S WHEN YOU CAME IN
TOUCH
WITH YOUR MASCULINE SIDE.
>> YEAH, I THINK SO.
>> J., WHEN DID YOU COME IN
TOUCH WITH YOUR FEMININE SIDE?
>> AT BIRTH.
>> WE'RE VERY DIFFERENT.
WE DON'T TRY AND BE THE SAME.
WE DON'T TRY AND BE DIFFERENT,
THOUGH, EITHER.
>> GIVE US POSES.
>> THAT WAS HILARIOUS.
>> THAT WAS THE SAME ONE.
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> DID WE DO THE SAME THING?
>> YOU GUYS DID THE SAME THING.
>> ONE'S GOT TWO LEFT FEET,
AND ONE'S GOT TWO RIGHT FEET.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND THEY DO LOOK
VERY DIFFERENT UP CLOSE.
>> THE CLOSEST THEY NEED TO BE
TO FASHION IS SITTING
IN A BACK ROW WATCHING.
(laughter)
>> ♪ ANTM 7 ♪
♪ A LITTLE PIECE OF HEAVEN... ♪
>> YEAH.
>> ♪ OH, YEAH ♪
>> OH, YEAH!
♪ MY NAME IS MEGAN ♪
♪ AND I LOVE TO ROCK 'N' ROLL ♪
YEAH, OH, BABY!
WHOO!
DID I KNOCK YOU OFF YOUR FEET?
>> GIRL, YOU KNOCKED ME
OFF OF MY FEET, OFF MY CHAIR
AND EVERYTHING ABOVE AND BEYOND.
>> WHOO!
WHY ARE YOU SO HAPPY TODAY?
>> I FEEL SO ALIVE,
AND I FEEL, LIKE, JUST ON TOP
OF THAT WORLD, YOU KNOW?
>> BUT YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF
AS DARK AND INTENSE.
>> THE KIND OF MUSIC
I LISTEN TO--
IT'S VERY DARK AND DEEP.
I LOVE HEAVY METAL
AND ROCK 'N' ROLL.
>> WHEN YOU PUT THAT SWIMSUIT
ON,
I WANT YOU TO COME BACK,
AND I WANT YOU
TO ROCK 'N' ROLL RUNWAY WALK.
(hard rock music playing)
>> OH, OH, OH.
>> WHOO-EE!
>> SHE HAD A PRETTY, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, THAT HOODED EYE
THAT'S VERY SULTRY.
>> WHEN SHE CAME CLOSE,
I JUST SAW REASON TO SAY "NO."
>> OH, REALLY?
WHEN SHE CAME CLOSE,
I SAID "MAYBE."
>> MY NAME'S JAEDA.
I'M 18,
AND I'M FROM PARKERSBURG, IOWA.
>> YOU SAY THAT AT YOUR SCHOOL,
PEOPLE GIVE YOU
A LOT OF COMPLIMENTS AND THAT
YOU'RE DEFINITELY THE HOT GIRL.
>> PEOPLE, YOU KNOW...
"WOW, YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL,"
YOU KNOW?
GUYS, LIKE,
THE WHOLE FOOTBALL TEAM...
>> SO WITH THE FOOTBALL TEAM,
DO YOU EVER GET CAUGHT
IN A HUDDLE?
>> NO--YEAH, A COUPLE TIMES.
WELL, I...
>> A LOT OF THE TIMES,
THE HOT GIRL ON CAMPUS
DOESN'T TRANSLATE INTO A MODEL,
AND SHE GETS HER FEELINGS HURT.
WHERE DO YOU THINK YOU FIT?
>> I THINK I'M A HOT GIRL
THAT CAN MODEL.
I DIDN'T COME HERE
TO SIT AND BE QUIET.
I CAME HERE TO GET MYSELF SEEN,
AND I ONLY HAVE A WEEK TO DO IT.
>> I THINK SHE PHOTOGRAPHS NICE.
>> (laughs)
MY NAME IS BECKY.
I'M PRETTY MUCH
AN ALL-AROUND AMERICAN GIRL
IN A SMALL TOWN WITH BIG DREAMS.
IN MY BABY BOOK,
IT SAYS WHEN MY PARENTS ASKED ME
WHEN I WAS 3 YEARS OLD--IT SAYS
THAT I WANT TO BE A MODEL.
MY MOM'S LIKE,
"OH, NO, NO, NO, NO, HONEY.
YOU RAISE PIGS.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE A MODEL."
I'M LIKE,"I'M GONNA BE A MODEL."
I WAS NOT GONNA GIVE UP.
I'M READY
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> SHE'S KIND OF
GENERALLY SWEET,
GENERALLY PRETTY,
GENERALLY NICE.
>> BUT DO YOU SEE A GENERAL
MODEL?
>> IT COULD BE GENERALLY BORING.
>> MONIQUE--19 YEARS OLD.
>> ARE YOU EXCITED TO BE HERE?
>> Y'ALL TRYIN' TO GIVE ME
A HEART ATTACK OVER HERE.
YOU NEED TO PICK ME.
I DESERVE IT.
I REALLY DESERVE IT.
>> WHY DO YOU DESERVE IT?
>> I'VE BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH
FROM LIFE, AND...
FROM, LIKE, MY CHILDHOOD,
AND OUT OF ALL MY SISTERS,
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
THE DARKER-SKINNED ONE.
THEY WOULD ALWAYS TALK ABOUT ME
LIKE, "OH, YOU KNOW, BLACK-ULA."
I USED TO TELL MY MOM
ALL THE TIME--
"I'M SO UGLY, BECAUSE..."
(crying)
>> IT'S OKAY.
ONE THING THAT A LOT OF GIRLS DO
THAT COME FROM TROUBLED
BACKGROUNDS
IS THEY TRY TO ENTER
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
BECAUSE IT GIVES THEM
SOME TYPE OF VALIDATION.
>> I WANT BIG THINGS
OUT OF LIFE.
I WANT TO JUST GO
AS FAR AS I CAN,
AS FAR AS MY MIND TAKES ME.
>> IF YOU ENTER THIS COMPETITION
OR THE MODELING WORLD
IN GENERAL,
THEY'RE GONNA BE SAYIN',
"YOUR HAIR IS THIS.
YOUR NOSE IS THAT"
DAY AFTER DAY AFTER DAY.
IT CAN BRING BACK
THOSE SAME EMOTIONS
THAT YOU HAD AS A LITTLE GIRL,
AND SOMETIMES EVEN WORSE.
>> IT'S A CHANCE
THAT I'M WILLIN' TO TAKE.
>> I SWEAR THAT REMINDS ME
OF A SWIMSUIT I HAD.
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO,
I HAD A SWIMSUIT CALENDAR
I SHOT IN JAMAICA.
>> REALLY?
>> AND MY BODY USED TO LOOK
LIKE THAT, TOO.
WORK IT OUT.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> EVERYBODY!
>> SHH... FOR ONE SECOND.
>> WE'RE ALL GONNA DO RUNWAY.
>> (cheering)
♪♪♪
>> I REALLY LIKE THE TWINS,
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THEY NEED
SOME SERIOUS GROOMING, THOUGH.
>> I GUESS THAT'S THEIR EDGE,
OR WHATEVER, TO BE TWINS,
BUT ONLY ONE PERSON CAN WIN,
SO WHY ARE THEY HOLDING ON
TO EACH OTHER SO MUCH?
>> OH, SHE'S WORKING IT.
>> HI. MY NAME IS EUGENA.
>> IT SAYS HERE
THAT YOU DON'T LIKE
THE LAST SEASON OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
GIRLS.
>> THEY'RE BORING.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE REALLY GENERIC,
LIKE, GINA--
SHE WAS TOO INNOCENT.
>> SO WHO'S BORING HERE?
>> THE TWINS ARE BORING.
I DON'T KNOW THEIR NAMES.
THAT LITTLE ROCKER CHICK--
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S ONLY ONE SIDE TO HER.
>> WHAT ARE YOU ABOUT?
>> I'M STRAIGHTFORWARD.
>> CLEARLY.
>> I DO TALK
BEHIND PEOPLE'S BACKS.
THAT'S JUST WHO WOMEN ARE.
THAT'S JUST WHO GIRLS ARE.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU'RE LIKEABLE?
>> YES, I'M LIKEABLE.
>> REALLY?
'CAUSE I DON'T THINK SO.
>> I'M VERY CARING.
Y'ALL DON'T BELIEVE ME?
>> NO!
>> NO,
I SAY THINGS THAT ARE MEAN,
BUT IN MODERATION.
>> THERE WAS NO MODERATION HERE
TODAY.
>> (screaming)
HI, HI, HI, HI.
HI, GUYS.
WHOO!
HI. MY NAME IS BRITTANY.
I WOULD BE THE TYPE OF PERSON
YOU WOULDN'T EXPECT.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY TALENTS?
>> I TAP DANCE.
>> YOU TAP DANCE?
>> YES.
♪♪♪
>> ♪ I WANNA BE ♪
♪ AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL ♪
>> LEFT, RIGHT, LEFT.
(laughing)
>> GIVE US A SPLIT.
OW!
>> (off-key) ♪ I WANT THIS ♪
♪ SO BADLY ♪
♪ SO PLEASE PICK ME ♪
>> ALL RIGHT.
I WROTE IT JUST FOR YOU.
>> YOU GOTTA GET THE BEAT.
>> (rapping)
♪ INTELLIGENT AND CLASSY ♪
♪ I GOT A CUTE LITTLE BOOTY ♪
♪ NOT ONLY BRAINS ♪
♪ I GOT THE BEAUTY ♪
♪ CONFIDENCE ♪
♪ BUT I'M NOT COCKY ♪
♪ I'M GOIN' TO THE TOP ♪
♪ DON'T YOU TRY AND STOP ME ♪
OHH!
>> OHH!
>> HEY.
>> OHH.
>> OHH. WORK IT OUT.
>> GO!
>> HEY, HEY,
DROP IT, DROP IT.
>> I'M BROOKE.
I'M 18 YEARS OLD, JUST A BABY.
I AM GIVIN' UP THE END
OF MY HIGH SCHOOL YEAR
TO BE HERE,
BECAUSE, GUYS,
THIS IS MY DREAM.
YOU GOTTA SACRIFICE
FOR WHAT YOU WANT,
AND I REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY WANT THIS.
>> SHE'S 5'7", BUT I SEE MODEL.
MISS EVA THE DIVA WAS SHORT,
BUT SHE WAS AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL
BECAUSE THAT PERSONALITY BROUGHT
HER THROUGH.
>> MY NAME'S MEGAN.
I'M 22.
THIS IS THE FIRST REAL
OPPORTUNITY
THAT'S PRESENTED ITSELF
AS FAR AS MODELING.
>> I KNOW YOU HAD
A VERY TRAUMATIC SOMETHING
HAPPEN TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY,
SO WHY DON'T YOU TELL US
THAT STORY?
>> WHEN I WAS 9,
I WAS IN A PLANE CRASH.
WE TOOK OFF,
AND IT WAS HAILING,
AND IT WAS WINDY.
THE PLANE--
IT STARTED KIND OF ROCKING.
THE LAST THING I DO REMEMBER
WAS I KIND OF LOOKED AT MY MOM
FOR COMFORT.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS
WE ACTUALLY CRASHED
IN, LIKE, A HUGE OPEN FIELD.
MY MOTHER--SHE EVENTUALLY DIED
IN THE AIRPLANE
WITH HYPOTHERMIA.
SHE HAPPENED TO BE PARTIALLY
ON MY BODY,
SO IT WAS ENOUGH
TO KEEP ME ALIVE FOR WARMTH.
>> YOU THINK SHE'S AN ANGEL FOR
YOU NOW?
>> OH, YEAH. YEAH.
LIKE, MY MOTHER
WAS SUCH A WONDERFUL PERSON
AND VERY GIVING AND CARING
TO EVERYONE.
>> SHE'S PROBABLY HERE
RIGHT NOW. WE JUST CAN'T SEE
HER.
>> I WAS JUST GONNA SAY THE
EXACT SAME THING.
SHE JUST GUIDED YOU RIGHT HERE.
>> SHE'S IN HERE SOMEWHERE.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY
OPENED MY EYES UP
TO HOW QUICK THINGS CAN CHANGE
IN LIFE, HOW... YOU KNOW,
FOR THE BETTER OR FOR WORSE.
I MEAN, FOR THE BETTER--
HERE I AM.
I REALLY HOPE TO MAKE IT
TO THE TOP.
>> HEY.
>> HI.
RAPUNZEL, RAPUNZEL.
>> MY NAME IS EVITA.
I'M 20 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE TWO KIDS,
AND I'M MARRIED.
MY HUSBAND'S IN IRAQ.
>> AND HOW IS IT LIKE
BEING WITHOUT HIM RIGHT NOW?
>> IT'S BECOME EASIER
BECAUSE I'VE ADJUSTED TO IT.
I WANT THIS MORE THAN ANYTHING,
AND I'M NOT GONNA LET
THAT DREAM GO
JUST BECAUSE I HAVE A FAMILY.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU CUT YOUR HAIR?
OKAY, THAT ANSWERS MY QUESTION.
THANKS.
>> THAT WAS AN EMOTIONAL
LITTLE QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED.
>> YEAH, I KNOW,
'CAUSE DID YOU SEE HER FACE?
SHE WAS LIKE, "HMM."
>> HMM.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS THOUGHT
ABOUT
HAVING THE ALL-AMERICAN FAMILY,
LIKE THE SOLDIER
AND THEN THE MODEL
AND THEN THE TWO LITTLE KIDS.
THIS IS WHAT I NEED TO DO
FOR MYSELF.
THIS IS, LIKE,
AN ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR ME.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S ALL RIGHT
FOR EVITA TO BE HERE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HER KIDS
ARE REALLY YOUNG.
I'M GETTING MAD RIGHT NOW
JUST THINKING ABOUT IT.
>> I'M NOT GONNA SACRIFICE
WATCHING MY DAUGHTER
TAKE HER FIRST CRAWL
OR WATCHING HER EAT
HER FIRST FOOD--
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'--
FOR NOTHING.
I'M GONNA BE IN THAT HOUSE.
IF I'M LEAVIN' MY KIDS,
I'LL BE THE LAST GIRL STANDIN'.
>> (screaming)
HELLO.
I WANNA SHOW PEOPLE
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE DIFFERENT,
'CAUSE I'M DIFFERENT.
I'M REAL DIFFERENT.
>> YOU SURVIVED CERVICAL CANCER.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE IT WORSE,
BUT IT WAS AN EMOTIONALLY
HARD THING FOR ME TO GO THROUGH.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY MORE COMMON
IN WOMEN THAN PEOPLE THINK.
>> ONE IN THREE WOMEN
WHO ARE SEXUALLY ACTIVE
WILL GET THE VIRUS
THAT CAUSES CERVICAL CANCER.
>> WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
>> I WANNA SHOW PEOPLE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
THE TYPICAL BLONDE.
RECENT EVENTS IN MY LIFE
HAVE LED ME TO REALIZE
THAT I CAN DO ANYTHING
THEY SORT OF THROW AT ME.
>> I LOVE THE WAY SHE LOOKS,
THIS GIRL.
I LOVE HER HEIGHT.
>> SHE'S ONE OF THOSE--
I THINK SHE COULD BE
A DIAMOND IN THE ROUGH.
>> SWIRL, BABY, SWIRL.
>> SWIRL.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT MEETING THE PANEL,
BUT I HOPE THEY'RE GONNA
BE THINKIN', "SHE'S GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> WHERE DO YOU WORK?
>> I WORK AT JEZEBEL'S.
I'M AN ENTERTAINER.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> YEAH.
>> JEZEBEL'S--IS THAT STRIPPING?
>> I'M NOT A STRIPPER.
I'M AN ENTERTAINER--
BIG DIFFERENCE.
IT'S ANOTHER PART OF MODELING,
IN A WAY, REALLY.
IT'S ANOTHER PART
OF THE FASHION WORLD, BUT...
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> I MEAN, LIKE, TO ME, IT IS,
BECAUSE--
>> I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
WITH YOU THAT STRIPPING'S
NOT A PART OF MODELING.
>> WELL, I'M NOT--
>> I'M NOT JUDGING YOU FOR BEING
AN EXOTIC DANCER OR A STRIPPER.
>> YEAH, YEAH. OH, YEAH. YEAH.
>> BUT IT'S--IT'S NOT MODELING.
>> I JUST HOPE THEY DON'T GET
THE WRONG IMPRESSION,
'CAUSE I LOVE BEING ME,
SO THEY'LL, LIKE,
LEARN TO LOVE ME.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SHE'S QUITE ATTRACTIVE.
>> I THINK SHE'D BE HAPPY
STRIPPING.
>> STRIPPIN' AT JEZEBEL'S.
>> (sarcastically) 'CAUSE IT'S
THE SAME AS MODELING.
>> MM.
>> WHOO, WHOO, WHOO.
>> SHE'S GOT THE TYRA BANKS
WIND IN THE HAIR THING.
(salsa music playing)
>> HI. MY NAME IS JASLENE.
I AM 19 YEARS OLD.
>> DID YOU LEARN ALL THAT
IN CATHOLIC SCHOOL?
>> I SHOULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
'CAUSE I DEVOTE MYSELF TO THIS.
EVERY DAY
IS LIKE A FASHION OPPORTUNITY.
AND I CAN PORTRAY
SO MANY DIFFERENT LOOKS.
>> GIVE ME SOME LOOKS.
WHAT LOOKS CAN YOU PORTRAY?
>> I CAN GIVE YOU NECK.
WHAT DO YOU WANT, NECK?
>> WHAT ELSE?
>> FIERCENESS.
>> GIVE ME SEXY.
GIVE ME SEXY LINGERIE.
GIVE ME CATALOG.
WHAT WAS THAT?
BREATH STINK?
>> LIKE... (gasps)
"OH, MY GOD.
I'M SO HAPPY.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
IT WAS NICE SEEING YOU.
HI."
GIRL, I WALK LIKE THIS
EVERY DAY, ALL DAY.
>> I DON'T THINK SHE LOOKS DRAG.
I THINK SHE JUST HAS A DRAG
PERSONALITY.
WORK IT, GIRL.
THAT'S--OH, THAT'S FIERCENESS.
>> FIERCE!
>> WELL.
>> HELLO. HOW ARE YOU?
>> YOUR NAME IS MELISSA ROSE,
BUT YOU GO BY WHAT?
>> MELROSE.
>> WHY'S THAT?
>> I DON'T NEED THAT "ISSA."
>> NO "ISSA"?
>> IT'S TOO MUCH.
PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER
MELISSA ROSE.
"I'M MELISSA ROSE.
I'M A COUNTRY SINGER."
THEY REMEMBER MELROSE.
I NEED TO SHOW AMERICA
WHAT REAL TOP MODELS ARE
AND WHAT WOMEN THAT
REALLY WANT THINGS ARE LIKE.
I CAN BE YOUR BEST FRIEND,
OR I CAN BE YOUR WORST ENEMY.
PICK OR CHOOSE.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IT MEANS
THAT I CAN BE REALLY NICE,
AND I CAN BE A COMPLETE BITCH.
>> WELL, THAT I CAN SEE.
>> I LOVE HIGH FASHION SO MUCH.
I MADE A LOT OF THE CLOTHES
THAT I'M WEARING HERE.
>> CAN YOU NAME
TOP FASHION DESIGNERS
THAT ARE REALLY RELEVANT
TO THE INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW?
>> CHANEL, DEREK LAM,
PROENZA SCHOULER, ZAC POSEN.
>> YOU PASS.
>> YOU KNOW,
I AM VERY IMPRESSED.
>> HI. HI, EVERYONE.
MY NAME'S LEANGELA.
I'M FROM COLUMBUS, OHIO,
AND I'M 21.
>> SO YOU WERE
THE FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
HOMECOMING QUEEN IN YOUR TOWN.
>> WHEN I WON,
EVERYONE WAS LIKE, "GIRL,
YOU DESERVED IT, YOU KNOW?
EVERYONE GETS ALONG WITH YOU.
YOU LIKE EVERYONE."
>> TALK ABOUT YOUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOUR MOTHER
AND BEING DROPPED OFF AT
THE CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
>> WE, AT THE TIME,
WERE JUST COMING OUT OF STAYING
IN A HOMELESS SHELTER,
AND SHE JUST DROPPED ME OFF.
SHE WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
"I'LL COME BACK
AND PICK YOU UP,"
BUT SHE NEVER CAME BACK, SO...
>> HOW OLD WERE YOU?
>> I WAS, LIKE, 10.
I DID STAY IN FOSTER CARE
FOR A FEW MONTHS.
IT WAS PROBABLY THE WORST TIME
OF MY CHILDHOOD.
I'VE BEEN FROM HOMELESS
TO HOMECOMING QUEEN, YOU KNOW,
IN A LIFETIME.
I HOPE THAT'S NOT THE HIGH POINT
OF MY LIFE, YOU KNOW?
I WANT TO TAKE IT
TO A HIGHER LEVEL.
>> IF LEANGELA MADE IT
TO THE NEXT ROUND
IN THIS COMPETITION,
IT WOULD ALMOST GIVE HER
THAT BOOST OF CONFIDENCE,
AND I THINK
WE WOULD SEE HER JUST TAKE OFF.
>> BLOSSOM.
>> I'M GINGER.
I JUST TURNED 18.
I WORKED AS A PAGE
FOR THE HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES
FOR FIVE MONTHS.
>> YOU SAID YOU WERE
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE,
SO THAT'S PRETTY CONSERVATIVE,
AND THIS FASHION INDUSTRY,
CHILD,
THEY GOT GAY BOYS AND SEX.
HOW DO YOU THINK
YOU CAN DEAL WITH THAT?
>> I'M NOT AFRAID TO GET
OUT THERE AND MEET PEOPLE.
I'M NOT AFRAID
TO SEE WHAT'S DIFFERENT.
>> YOU ARE STANDING
ON THAT PULPIT,
AND YOU ARE SAYING THE THINGS
THAT YOU THINK ARE CORRECT,
BUT I THINK THAT THERE IS
A GIRL UNDERNEATH THERE
THAT DOES NOT HAVE THIS VENEER.
WHO THE HELL ARE YOU?
>> I AM GINGER.
>> KEEP TALKIN'.
>> IT'S REALLY HARD.
I'VE DONE BALLET MY WHOLE LIFE.
>> TALK LIKE THIS.
>> THIS IS AN AWESOME
EXPERIENCE, AND...
>> DROP IT LIKE IT'S HOT.
DROP IT DOWN.
DROP, DROP.
OKAY. KEEP TALKIN'.
>> LIKE THAT?
>> YEAH. WHAT ELSE?
GIVE ME A HEAD FLIP.
GO DOWN AND UP.
WHAT MAKES YOU BETTER?
>> I AM BETTER BECAUSE I KNOW
HOW TO GET THROUGH HARD THINGS.
I KNOW HOW TO BRING IT,
AND I KNOW HOW
TO WALK DOWN THAT RUNWAY.
>> WORK IT OUT.
♪♪♪
>> THE TIME HAS COME
THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
OUR FIRST CUT.
>> THIS IS REALLY NERVE-RACKING.
THEY MIGHT PUT
ME AND MY SISTER BOTH IN THERE,
OR THEY MIGHT PUT
JUST ONE OR NEITHER.
>> THERE'S A SALON BEHIND US,
AND INSIDE THAT SALON,
YOU WILL FIND 21 MAGAZINES
WITH TYRA ON THE COVER.
IN EACH OF THOSE MAGAZINES,
THERE IS A PHOTO TEAR SHEET.
>> AND LORD HELP YOU
IF YOU'RE NOT INSIDE ONE,
BECAUSE...
>> THOSE 21 MAGAZINES
REPRESENT THE 21 YOUNG LADIES
WHO ARE GONNA CONTINUE ON
IN THE COMPETITION.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YEAH!
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> I'M NOT READY,
'CAUSE FOR SOME REASON,
I ALWAYS GET TRAMPLED
AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
ON THE COUNT OF THREE--
ONE...
>> TWO...
THREE.
>> THREE.
>> (screaming)
>> WE'RE EXCITED.
THE TWINS ARE IN THE NEXT ROUND.
>> (screaming)
>> A DREAM COME TRUE.
IT'S LIKE ALL MY PRAYERS
AND BLESSINGS--
IT'S JUST EVERYTHING.
>> (screaming)
♪♪♪
>> I'M EXTREMELY EXCITED!
I GOT A PICTURE.
I'M GONNA BE A SUPERMODEL
AND STILL BE A MOM AND A WIFE,
BUT TIMES TEN.
>> THERE'S NONE LEFT?
>> HEY, GIRL.
>> (screaming)
>> HEY, I DIDN'T MAKE IT,
BUT IT'S COOL.
>> I'M GONNA KEEP ON
LOVIN' MYSELF.
I AIN'T GONNA LET THIS
BE A DOWNFALL FOR ME.
THAT'S BEIN' A SORE LOSER,
AND I AIN'T NO SORE LOSER.
(indistinct conversations)
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THIS.
>> THESE GIRLS ARE WEEDED OUT,
AND NOW HERE'S
MY REAL COMPETITION.
LET'S GET IT ON.
LET'S FOCUS.
>> (screaming)
♪♪♪
>> WE ARE THROWING YOU GUYS
RIGHT INTO WORK.
>> (cheering)
>> SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS SEND YOU GIRLS
TO A VERY IMPORTANT PHOTO SHOOT.
>> (cheering)
>> OH, I LOVE TAKING PHOTOS.
I'M SO STOKED
TO GO TO THE PHOTO SHOOT
AND ACTUALLY, LIKE, GET STARTED
WITH THIS COMPETITION.
>> WE HAVE MAKEUP
AND HAIR EXTENSIONS HERE
SO THAT YOU GIRLS
CAN BRING YOUR LOOK TOGETHER.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU GUYS
15 MINUTES TO GET READY.
>> (cheering)
♪♪♪
>> I'M GONNA TRY
TO STAY FOCUSED
AND DO EVERYTHING I HAVE TO DO,
YOU KNOW, TO STAY ON TOP.
♪♪♪
>> CLEARLY,
YOU GUYS HAVE NOT GONE
THROUGH THE HAIR AND MAKEUP
BEAUTY SCHOOL,
BUT FOR THOSE WHO TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THOSE HAIR EXTENSIONS,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
HELP YOU OUT THIS MORNING,
BECAUSE THE THING
I DIDN'T TELL YOU
IS TODAY YOU GIRLS
ARE GOING TO BE SHOOTING...
NUDE.
>> (gasps)
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD!
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
OH, MY GOD!
>> I'M CONSERVATIVE,
AND I THINK IT'S WRONG
TO EXPOSE YOUR PRIVATE PARTS
FOR PEOPLE TO SEE,
AND I JUST CAN'T DO IT.
>> HAVE FUN.
>> FOR THOSE WHO TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THOSE HAIR EXTENSIONS,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
HELP YOU OUT THIS MORNING,
BECAUSE TODAY YOU GIRLS
ARE GOING TO BE SHOOTING NUDE.
>> (gasping and screaming)
>> I'M FROM A SMALL TOWN,
AND I'M A GOOD GIRL.
IT'S JUST REALLY HARD
FOR ME TO KNOW, LIKE,
THAT I'M GONNA DO THIS
AND, LIKE, FULFILL MY DREAM,
BUT GO HOME AND HAVE
SO MANY PEOPLE MAD AT ME.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT NUDITY IN A SHOT
CAN BE VERY, VERY CLASSIC,
AND THERE'S A FINE LINE
BETWEEN SLEAZY VERSUS SEXY.
>> OR CLASSY VERSUS TRASHY.
>> NOW YOU GUYS
ARE IN GREAT HANDS.
TODAY BRYAN IS
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE BOTTOM PART YET, GUYS.
I'M, LIKE, NO!
I WANT...
>> BUT YOU LOOK LIKE ME.
>> YOU NERVOUS?
>> YEAH.
>> WHY? WHAT'S THE ISSUE?
TELL US.
>> I-I JUST CAN'T POSE
IN THE NUDE.
>> YOU CAN'T?
REALIZE THAT IT'S GONNA AFFECT
YOUR STANDING
IN THE COMPETITION.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
>> GINGER CLEARLY
WON'T EVEN GET NAKED
IN FRONT OF HERSELF.
SO, I MEAN, THERE'S NO WAY
IN HELL SHE'S GONNA DO IT
IN FRONT OF ALL THESE PEOPLE.
>> I WANT TO SEE CONFIDENCE.
>> (cheering)
>> AAH!
>> OKAY.
>> I THINK THERE IS A FEROCITY
IN MY EYES,
AND I THINK IT'LL COME OUT
AS A REALLY INTENSE PICTURE.
>> I THINK I DID IT.
I'VE BEGUN TO SIT ON THE TOP
OF A HOTEL NAKED.
>> MONIQUE.
READY? ONE, TWO, THREE.
>> IT WAS REALLY, REALLY WEIRD,
BUT I'M EXCITED.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
THE PICTURES.
>> I AM SCARED OUT OF MY MIND.
>> IF ANYBODY SHOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT, LIKE, GETTING NAKED,
THAT DEFINITELY SHOULD BE ME.
LIKE, MY KID IS GONNA
BE WATCHING THIS ONE DAY
AND BE, LIKE,
THERE IS MY MOM NAKED.
>> OH!
>> EVITA!
>> WHOO!
>> THAT'S COOL, DUDE.
>> THANK YOU.
JAEDA.
GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS WAS A BIG CHALLENGE
FOR ME,
BUT I WASN'T AS SCARED
AS I IMAGINED I WOULD BE.
>> OKAY, THAT'S NICE.
OKAY, READY?
HERE WE GO.
>> IF YOU REALLY WANT THIS,
THIS SHOULDN'T BE NO PROBLEM.
>> JUST BECAUSE, LIKE, I DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE BEING NAKED,
DOESN'T MEAN
THAT I DON'T WANT IT, LIKE,
MORE THAN ANYBODY, YOU KNOW?
IT'S JUST THAT I'M NOT--
I WASN'T RAISED LIKE THIS.
>> BUT YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
NOT DOING WHAT IT TAKES TO--
>> DID I NOT SAY I WASN'T
GONNA DO IT?
I'M GONNA DO IT.
>> OH, OKAY.
NO, WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT--
>> OH, THE DRAMA.
>> IT'S A HARD THING.
I'M NOT JUST GONNA BE, LIKE,
WALKING AROUND NAKED--
BE LIKE, "WHOO!" YOU KNOW?
LIKE, "I FEEL GREAT!"
BECAUSE I DON'T FEEL GREAT,
BUT I JUST HOPE I HAVE A PLACE
TO GO HOME TO, YOU KNOW?
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HARD FOR ME.
>> I'M GONNA WANT
TO SEE CONFIDENCE...
>> OKAY.
>> CONFIDENCE AND THAT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE IN YOUR OWN SKIN.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
YOU HAVE CLOTHES ON.
GO AHEAD ON UP.
>> WHOO!
♪♪♪
>> COME THIS WAY A LITTLE BIT.
THAT'S NICE.
GOOD.
GREAT.
PRETTY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD JOB.
>> GOOD JOB!
>> WHOO!
>> (cheering)
>> WAY TO PULL THROUGH.
>> I FEEL BETTER
NOW THAT I DID IT.
I WAS SO NERVOUS,
BUT I FEEL REALLY CONFIDENT
ABOUT THE SHOOT,
AND I THINK I DID REALLY WELL.
>> ONE, TWO, THREE...
♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> THAT'S NICE.
THANK YOU.
>> WHOO!
>> BEING A MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO BE OPEN.
YOU CANNOT BE SHELTERED.
IF YOU CAN'T DO THAT,
THEN I DON'T KNOW
HOW FAR YOU'D MAKE IT.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> AMANDA'S GOING FIRST.
>> I'M FIRST.
>> SHE'S THE BRAVE TWIN WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE SORT OF....
>> YEAH.
>> UM, NAKED EXPERIENCES.
>> OH, IT'S REALLY SLIPPERY
UP HERE!
>> WHOO! THAT'S MY TWIN!
>> THAT'S NICE.
YOU'RE DOING GOOD.
MICHELLE, YOU'RE NEXT.
WE GO ONE, TWO, THREE.
♪♪♪
>> WHOO!
>> GOOD.
THANK YOU.
>> JUST KEEP GOING.
CHANGE IT UP.
>> THIS IS A TASTEFULLY DONE
NUDE PHOTO
THAT PRETTY MUCH GLORIFIED
THE HUMAN BODY,
AND THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT TO ME.
>> GINGER, YOU'RE UP.
>> I-I CAN'T.
>> I KNOW--
I KNOW IT'S HARD.
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO IT?
>> I CAN'T.
THANK YOU.
>> I'M MAD AT THE FACT
THAT THESE GIRLS
WANT TO BE MODELS,
BUT THEY'RE, LIKE, OBJECTING
AT THE FACT
THAT THEY'VE GOT TO BE NUDE,
AND I REALLY DON'T WANT
TO HEAR IT.
>> GREAT.
PERFECT.
>> WHOO!
>> GO, MELROSE!
>> GO, BRITTANY!
>> READY? ONE, TWO.
CHANGE IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
>> OW!
>> GINGER, WE CAN DO IT
SO YOU'RE TOTALLY COVERED
THE WHOLE TIME YOU'RE UP THERE
OR HAVE SOMEBODY GO UP THERE
WITH YOU.
>> YOU KNOW, LEAVE HER ALONE.
IF SHE DON'T WANT TO DO IT,
BIG DEAL.
>> WHOO!
>> AT FIRST,
GINGER COULDN'T DO IT,
BUT WE HAD TALKED TO HER,
AND SHE FINALLY
MADE UP HER MIND.
>> WHOO!
>> COME ON!
>> CAN YOU JUST DO IT?
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> COME ON!
>> WHOO!
>> THAT'S IT.
>> WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
IT'S NOT IMPORTANT TO ME
JUST TO WIN SOMETHING.
I'M GONNA STICK
TO MY MORALS AND STANDARDS,
NO MATTER WHAT.
>> GINGER ONLY TOOK
TWO PICTURES.
I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR
TO EVERYBODY ELSE.
I FEEL THAT SHE SHOULD
GET AUTOMATICALLY ELIMINATED.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO WE GOT
OUR SEMIFINALISTS,
BUT YOU ALL KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO NOW.
WE'VE GOT THESE GIRLS,
AND WE'VE GOT TO NARROW IT DOWN
TO THE FINALISTS.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, LET'S START WITH MEGG.
>> I'M GONNA BE HONEST WITH YOU.
SHE WAS NOT MY FAVORITE.
>> BUT SHE'S KIND OF LIKE,
"YEAH."
>> YEAH!
OH, BABY!
>> UNTIL LOOK--
SHE LOOKS LIKE A MODEL!
>> LEANGELA.
>> I'M GONNA SAY
I LOVE LEANGELA'S AIRPORT SHOT.
THERE IS SUCH A SENSITIVITY.
>> LET'S SEE HER NUDE CLOSEUP.
>> SHE WENT A BIT MAD MAX.
BUT WAIT, I'M NOT MAD AT THAT--
I JUST WISH I'D GET
SOME MORE EXPRESSION
IN HER FACE.
>> ALL RIGHTY.
UP NEXT--MEGAN.
>> SHE TOLD US
A VERY POWERFUL STORY.
>> WHEN I WAS 9,
I WAS IN A PLANE CRASH.
>> I THINK SHE CAN HANDLE
THIS BUSINESS,
BUT I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
AT HER PROPORTIONS.
>> CARIDEE.
>> PERSONALITY-WISE,
I THINK SHE'S WILLING
TO GO 199%.
>> OKAY, LET'S SEE HER CLOSEUP.
AND WHAT'S UP WITH THE HAIR?
EUGENA.
>> UP CLOSE, SHE'S EU-GENIUS.
>> OOH!
BUT IT'S WEIRD,
'CAUSE WHEN SHE'S WRONG,
SHE DOESN'T EVEN
LOOK LIKE A MODEL AT ALL,
AND WHEN SHE'S RIGHT,
SHE'S REALLY GOOD.
MELROSE.
>> WE LIKE MELROSE.
>> TO ME, SHE REMINDS ME
OF THE GIRLS FROM, LIKE,
THE LATE '80s.
>> BUT NOW I THINK WE ARE MOVING
TO THE '80s,
SO I THINK SHE COULD BE
A GOOD CHOICE.
>> THANK GOD,
'CAUSE MY HAIR IS HUGE.
CHRISTIAN.
>> I LOVE THE FACT
THAT SHE UNDERSTANDS
THE TYRA BANKS POSES,
THE TYRA BANKS A-B-C's.
LET'S JUST TAKE A CLOSEUP LOOK
AT CHRISTIAN'S NUDE,
BECAUSE I BARELY,
SCARCELY SEE A NECK.
I SEE HEAD AND SHOULDERS.
>> ALL RIGHT, BRITTANY.
>> LOOK AT HER FACE.
THERE'S A HUGE QUESTION MARK.
LIKE, AM I DOING IT?
>> BUT THAT CAN BE TAUGHT.
>> JASLENE.
>> YOU MEAN CHA CHA DiGREGORIO,
HONEY.
GIVE ME CATALOGUE.
>> OH!
SHE'S FEELING IT.
SHE'S FEELING THE WIND
IN HER FACE.
>> I THINK JASLENE
IS A BIT HARD.
CAN SHE SOFTEN UP?
>> I'M ON THE FENCE.
>> GINGER.
I LOVE GINGER'S FACE,
I GOT TO SAY.
>> I DO, TOO.
>> BUT SHE ONLY DID TWO FRAMES,
AND SO THAT'S SHOWING SOMEONE
WHO'S A LITTLE BIT UNWILLING
TO COOPERATE.
>> EVITA.
DON'T CRY FOR HER.
>> SEEMS A LITTLE VACANT.
>> IT'S, LIKE, I'M PRETTY.
TAKE THE PICTURE.
>> THAT'S IT.
THERE'S NOTHING COMING FROM HER.
>> BUT I THINK SHE LOOKS LIKE
AN AMAZING NATIVE AMERICAN
GORGEOUS BEAUTY.
A.J.
I SEE A GREAT CANVAS
FOR ME TO CREATE SOMETHING.
>> ONE THING
ABOUT A.J.'s PICTURE--
HER SKIN LOOKS SO ALABASTER
AND LUMINESCENT,
BUT THE FACE IS OFF.
ANCHAL.
>> ANCHAL LOOKS LIKE
A MISS WORLD PAGEANT WINNER.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S A MODEL.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT HER,
IT SCARES ME HOW PRETTY SHE IS.
JAEDA.
>> (deep voice) WELL, FOR ME,
I THINK SHE LOOKS
A BIT MANNISH.
>> BUT I THINK
THOSE MASCULINE FEATURES--
THEY PHOTOGRAPH WELL,
BECAUSE IT'S BONE STRUCTURE.
>> SHE'S MORE MASCULINE
THAN I AM.
>> WELL, MAYBE SHE NEEDS TO--
>> SHE IS!
>> BECKY.
I LIKE HER CHEEKBONES.
>> I DO LIKE HER FACE.
I WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S
A PERSONALITY BEHIND ALL THAT.
>> TO ME, SHE LOOKS
KIND OF SAFE,
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING IN HER EYE
THAT SAYS, "DON'T SLEEP."
BROOKE.
SHE LOOKS A MESS WITH THAT HAIR.
>> A LOT OF GIRLS,
WHEN THEY STEP
INTO THIS INDUSTRY,
THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO STYLE THEMSELVES.
YOU HAD YOUR MAMA,
SO SHE TOLD YOU,
"UNH-UNH, HONEY.
WE'RE GONNA PUT THE PIECE
OVER HERE."
'CAUSE YOUR MOM LOVES
THROWING A PIECE RIGHT
ON THE BACK OF HER HEAD, RIGHT?
>> MY MAMA DOES LOVE A BUN.
>> I DO THINK
THAT BROOKE HAS SOMETHING.
>> SHE RAPS,
SO SHE'S GOT SOME FLAVOR
TO SAVOR.
MONIQUE.
>> SHE JUST MADE
MY EYES FLUTTER.
>> MONIQUE IS THE TYPE OF GIRL
WHO COULD BOOK
COSMETIC CAMPAIGNS,
HIGH-FASHION EDITORIALS
AND LIQUOR--
UH, WELL, YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING?
BUT NO, LITERALLY.
>> AMANDA, ONE OF THE TWINS.
WORK.
I LOVE THAT SHE JUST IS GIVING
ENERGY AND SEX APPEAL,
BECAUSE AMANDA'S
THE GIRLY TWIN.
>> WELL, I THINK SHE WOULD BE
VERY COMFORTABLE TO WORK WITH.
>> UP NEXT IS MICHELLE,
THE TOMBOY TWIN.
I LIKE IT.
I LIKE THE WAVY HAIR.
SHE'S JUST GOT THAT MODEL THING,
THAT PLAIN-JANE MODEL THING.
>> WELL, IF I HAD TO CHOOSE
ONE TWIN OVER THE OTHER,
I WOULD CHOOSE AMANDA.
>> AND I WOULD CHOOSE MICHELLE.
>> YEAH.
>> OH, YOU DON'T LIKE THE TWINS?
>> I LOVE ONE OF THE TWINS.
I JUST CAN'T REMEMBER
WHICH ONE IT IS.
♪♪♪
>> THIS HAS BEEN A LONG WEEK,
HASN'T IT?
>> YES.
>> LOTS OF, "OH, MY GOSH.
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN?
BECAUSE IF MY NAME IS CALLED,
MY LIFE CAN CHANGE."
THE FIRST GIRL
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> MELROSE.
>> AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
>> THE SECOND NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> JAEDA.
>> JAEDA!
>> GOOD JOB!
>> (gasps)
WHOO.
>> THE NEXT NAME...
>> MICHELLE.
>> (cheering)
>> MICHELLE,
YOU SEEM IN SHOCK...
>> YEAH.
>> SPEECHLESS.
EUGENA.
>> AAH!
WHOO!
>> THE NEXT NAME...
>> (rapping)
♪ HER NAME IS BROOKE ♪
♪ AND SHE GOT SHOOK ♪
>> (screams)
I'VE GOT A LOT OF PERSONALITY
YOU JUST CAN'T BOTTLE.
HERE I AM, GIRLS.
I'M ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL"!
>> WHOO!
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> ANCHAL.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I KNOW YOU SAY
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN,
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT DO.
>> (voice breaking) THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> A.J.
>> HELL, YEAH!
>> WHOO!
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> CHRISTIAN.
>> WHOO!
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> MEGG.
>> YAY! WHOO!
ROCK 'N' ROLL, BABY!
THAT FEELS GOOD!
HA HA!
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> MEGAN.
>> WHOO!
>> MEGAN!
>> HEY.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
>> CARIDEE, COME ON UP HERE.
>> (sobbing)
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> THE NEXT NAME...
>> AMANDA.
>> WHOO!
>> I KNOW WHY YOU HAD
THAT WEIRD LOOK ON YOUR FACE
WHEN I CALLED YOUR NAME.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU WERE, LIKE,
"WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER ONE?"
YOU GUYS BOTH DID A GOOD JOB.
I ONLY HAVE
ONE... NAME... LEFT,
AND THAT GIRL'S NAME
THAT I CALL--
SHE'LL HAVE A 1 IN A 13 CHANCE
OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THE LAST GIRL
THAT WILL JOIN
THESE 12 LUCKY LADIES OVER HERE
IS...
>> ♪ MONIQUE ♪
>> (screams)
(sobbing)
I HAVE NEVER BEEN PICKED
FOR ANYTHING.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
HAVE BEEN HURTING SO LONG ABOUT,
ABOUT BEING A DARK-SKINNED
BLACK GIRL?
AND THERE ARE SO MANY
BROWN SISTERS LOOKING AT YOU
AND SAYING, "WOW!
SHE'S BEAUTIFUL, AND THAT MEANS
I'M BEAUTIFUL, TOO."
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU GUYS.
>> WHOO!
>> MAMA'S COMING HOME,
BUT IT DON'T MEAN
MAMA CAN'T MODEL.
>> COMPARED TO THE OTHER GIRLS,
I SACRIFICED WAY MORE.
PUTTING MY KIDS THROUGH,
"WHERE'S MOM?"
PUT MY LIFE ON HOLD,
BECAUSE I HONESTLY THOUGHT THAT
I WAS GONNA MAKE IT.
>> GIVE ME A HUG.
>> I FELT LIKE
I WANTED TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
WHEN I DID THE NUDITY SCENE,
BUT PART OF ME WANTED TO STAY,
AND THAT PART IS SAD.
>> I'M NOT GIVING UP.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T GIVE UP.
>> I'M COMING BACK.
>> OKAY, GIVE ME A HUG.
>> (screaming)
>> COME ON, GUYS.
>> SWIRL, SWIRL!
ANCHAL.
WHOA. HEY, BABY. YEAH.
>> HELL, YEAH, I'M READY.
BRING IT ON.
GET ME NAKED UP THERE AGAIN.
I'LL DO IT AGAIN.
>> BOOM. BOOM. BOOM. BAM!
HIT IT. WHOO!
>> IT'S AWESOME.
IT'S LIKE,
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HOUSE!
YEAH, BABY!
>> WHOO!
♪♪♪
>> DON'T GO AWAY.
THE SECOND PART OF OUR 2 HOUR
PREMIER IS NEXT.
>> OUR 13 FINALISTS
GET THE KEYS
TO THEIR NEW CASTLE.
>> (screaming)
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> AND MONIQUE
TAKES EUGENA'S BED.
>> I JUST DECIDED
TO JUST PEE ON THE BED TODAY.
>> I WANTED TO FIGHT HER.
>> THEN I UNLEASH
MY INNER DIVA.
(roaring)
>> WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED FIRST?
FIND OUT NEXT.
♪♪
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> WE'RE ON HOLLYWOOD BOULEVARD,
AND IT'S ALMOST SURREAL
THAT WE'RE STARTING.
IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE ON A MISSION,
AND WE'RE ALL WALKING TOGETHER
TOWARDS IT.
>> I AM ACTUALLY HERE.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
LIKE MY ICON TYRA.
BEING SO CLOSE TO HER
WAS JUST LIKE
TOUCHING MY DREAM.
>> HEY!
>> HEY.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> SO CONGRATULATIONS
TO ALL THE FINAL 13.
>> WHOO!
>> GIVE YOURSELF SOME APPLAUSE.
>> TODAY YOU WILL GET A CHANCE
TO STRUT YOUR STUFF.
I MEAN, LIKE, DUH.
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> BUT FIRST,
YOU'LL NEED SOME CLOTHES,
AND THAT'S WHERE OUR GUESTS
COME IN.
>> (cheering)
>> GIRLS,
YOUR DESIGNERS FOR TODAY--
ELMER AVENUE.
>> HI, LADIES.
WE'RE THE DESIGNERS
FROM ELMER AVE.
>> HERE'S YOUR FIRST CHALLENGE.
PLEASE BRING OUT THE MODELS.
>> (cheering)
♪♪
>> WHOO!
>> WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE DOING
IS TAKING ONE OF THE GUYS
THAT YOU SEE.
YOU PICK YOUR MAN,
AND YOU TAKE HIS OUTFIT.
FEMINIZE THE OUTFIT
AS MUCH AS YOU CAN.
>> MAKE IT YOURS,
AND MAKE IT LOOK GOOD.
>> THEN YOU NEED TO REMEMBER,
ELMER AVE.
IS ALL ABOUT ROCK 'N' ROLL.
>> ROCK 'N' ROLL!
>> GIRLS,
YOU WILL GET ON THAT STAGE
AND UNDRESS YOUR MAN.
GO!
>> I WANTED THE FIRST, LIKE, GUY
THAT CAME OUT,
AND HE'S, LIKE, REALLY HOT.
>> THE OTHER GIRLS
WERE DEFINITELY LOOKING
AT THE MEN,
BUT I'M LOOKING AT THE CLOTHES,
LIKE WHICH OUTFIT'S GONNA FIT?
>> THEY'RE DEFINITELY
ROCK 'N' ROLL STYLE,
AND I THOUGHT IT WOULD KIND OF,
LIKE, GIVE ME AN ADVANTAGE,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT I'M
SO USED TO.
>> TICKTOCK.
>> WELL, THIS STYLE
WASN'T MY STYLE AT ALL.
I DON'T KNOW NOTHING ABOUT ROCK.
>> AND LINE UP, BITCHES.
>> HOOTERS...
>> (high-pitched voice)
READY?
>> HIT IT.
♪♪
>> I GOT REALLY NERVOUS
AS SOON AS I GOT ON THE STAGE.
ALL I HAVE TO WORK ON
IS MY CONFIDENCE,
AND I HAVE TO WORK ON MY BODY.
>> NEXT.
>> WORK IT.
>> THIS IS GREAT,
'CAUSE RUNWAY
HAS ALWAYS BEEN MY FORTE.
I RULE THE RUNWAY.
♪ ACCELERATE ♪
>> ONCE I HIT THE STAGE,
I'M JUST--
I'M--BAM--CONFIDENT.
I'M MODELING.
I JUST WANT TO HAVE
TOTAL SEX APPEAL
AND SELL THIS OUTFIT.
♪♪
>> I REALLY BELIEVE
I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE THE NEXT TOP MODEL,
'CAUSE I'VE BEEN THROUGH
THINGS IN LIFE
THAT SHOULD HAVE BROKE ME.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT A TOP MODEL
HAS TO HAVE.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE THAT STRENGTH.
>> ALL RIGHT, BABY!
>> LET'S GO.
>> WHOO!
>> BRAVO!
>> SMASHING!
>> CONGRATULATIONS, GIRLS.
SOME OF YOU DID
AN EXCELLENT JOB.
SOME OF YOU, ON THE OTHER HAND,
AH, MAYBE MISSED THE MARK
A LITTLE BIT.
>> BUT WE DEFINITELY
ALL CAME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT CONGRATULATIONS...
>> MELROSE, YOU WIN.
>> (laughs)
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> MELROSE, WE THOUGHT
YOU DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
WITH THE CLOTHES.
YOU DID A GREAT WALK.
YOU WILL RECEIVE A GREAT PRIZE
THAT WILL BE REVEALED
TO YOU LATER.
>> THANKS AGAIN, LADIES.
BYE.
>> DID A GREAT JOB WITH THE
CLOTHES
I'M LIKE, "I WON.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS!"
>> (cheering)
>> WE GET OUTSIDE,
AND THERE'S A STRETCH
ESCALADE LIMOUSINE.
>> WHOO!
>> I WAS LIKE,
♪ OH ♪
>> OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> AND WE GET IN THE LIMO,
AND IT'S DECKED OUT
HEAD-TO-TOE--
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THIS IS OUR RIDE!
>> (cheering)
>> THIS IS HOW CHRISTIAN
IS SUPPOSED TO BE TREATED--
LIKE A QUEEN.
>> THIS IS SO RAD.
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> IT'S TYRA MAIL!
>> (cheering)
>> WHAT IS THE KEY...
>> "WE'VE ALL GOT ISSUES.
STEP INTO MY WORLD
TO EXPERIENCE SOME OF MINE.
YOUR SUBSCRIPTION
HAS JUST ARRIVED."
>> WE ARE ON OUR WAY
TO OUR HOUSE.
>> WHOO!
♪♪
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> OH, LOOK AT IT!
>> (screaming)
>> I OPENED THE DOOR,
AND THERE'S THIS HUGE PICTURE
OF TYRA,
AND I'M, LIKE,
"OH, I'VE MADE IT."
>> (cheering)
♪♪
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS FREAKIN' BEAUTIFUL.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> THERE'S PICTURES OF TYRA
EVERYWHERE.
>> IT'S KIND OF LIKE
A "TYRA" MAGAZINE THEME
THROUGH THE WHOLE HOUSE...
>> WHICH IS REALLY COOL,
BECAUSE WE ALL WANT
TO BE COVER GIRLS.
>> "WELCOME TO 'TYRA,'
THE MAGAZINE DEDICATED
TO ALL YOU ASPIRING DIVAS,
BILLBOARD BEAUTIES
AND RUNWAY SHOWSTOPPERS,
WHO MIGHT NEED A TIP OR TWO,
NOW THAT YOU'VE GOTTEN
ONE STILETTO IN THE DOOR
OF THE INTERNATIONAL
FASHION BIZ.
I CREATED THIS PUBLICATION
FOR THE FASHION MUSES
OF TOMORROW,
WHO AREN'T AFRAID
TO GO AFTER THEIR DREAMS TODAY.
BEST OF LUCK, AND REMEMBER,
IF YOU HAVE ISSUES
WITH AN ISSUE,
DON'T JUST SIT THERE.
TELL ME ABOUT IT
IN THE CONFESSIONAL.
XOXO. TYRA."
>> RING RING.
HELLO.
OH, YEAH?
I GET TO LIVE
MY WILDEST DREAM TODAY?
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> YOU GUYS, COME OUT HERE!
>> (screaming)
>> HERE I COME.
>> THIS IS TOP MODEL, BABY.
TOP MODEL!
>> WHOA!
>> IF THEY COME BACK UP HERE
AND TRY TO TAKE MY BED,
I'LL BE LIKE, "NO WAY."
THERE WERE ONLY 11 BEDS.
MONIQUE AND CHRISTIAN
WERE THE UNFORTUNATE LOSERS
IN THE BED SITUATION.
>> THAT MEANS GIRLS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO SLEEP HERE.
>> I AM NOT SLEEPING
ON NO BEANBAG.
I WILL NOT DO THAT.
PINK IS WHAT IT IS.
(whispers)
WHOSE IS THIS?
(normal voice)
I POLITELY MOVED THEIR STUFF
AND MARKED MY TERRITORY.
(whispers)
LET'S SEE THIS.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GONNA WANT
TO SLEEP HERE NOW.
(normal voice)
I DESERVE A BED.
SO IF I HAVE TO FIGHT
FOR MY BED,
I'M GONNA FIGHT FOR IT.
>> I'M TIRED.
>> WHOSE SIDE IS WET?
>> HEY, THAT'S MY BED
RIGHT THERE.
>> DAMN, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST DECIDED
TO JUST PEE ON THE BED TODAY.
>> DID YOU DO THIS?
>> YEAH, I DID.
>> THE BATHROOM
IS DOWN THE HALL, MONIQUE.
>> THAT WASN'T YOUR BED?
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHOSE BED IT WAS.
>> IT'S MY BED.
>> IT WAS SOMEONE ELSE'S BED,
MONIQUE.
>> NO, IT WASN'T.
MY STUFF WAS OVER HERE.
>> I'M SLEEPING RIGHT HERE
UNDERNEATH TYRA.
>> I'M MARKING MY TERRITORY.
>> MONIQUE JUST STOLE MY BED.
THIS BITCH THINKS
THAT SHE OWNS EVERYTHING.
SHE'S BEING A PUNK,
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T TELL ME
TO MY FACE THAT SHE WAS
GONNA TRY TO TAKE MY BED.
I WANTED TO FIGHT HER.
>> DON'T PLAY WITH ME.
I'M GONNA HAVE A BED.
I DON'T CARE.
AND THEY CAN CALL ME
"DAMN DIVA" OR WHATEVER.
I DON'T CARE.
YOU GUYS CAN ALL BITE ME.
>> HEY, EXCUSE ME.
>> BEFORE YOU USE ANYTHING
IN THIS KITCHEN,
I WOULD RECOMMEND CLEANING IT.
>> PROBABLY WISE.
>> MELROSE IS TRYING
TO BE THE MOM OF THE HOUSE,
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE
AREN'T FEELING.
>> OKAY, THE RULE IS
I'M MAKING THIS FOR EVERYONE,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA CLEAN
THE DISHES, OKAY?
>> MELROSE--
SHE FOUND IT UPON HERSELF
TO START COOKING
AND TELLING PEOPLE WHAT TO DO,
TO CLEAN THE DISHES.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT'S, LIKE,
YOU'RE NOT MY MOTHER.
DON'T TELL ME WHAT TO DO.
>> IS ANYONE WILLING
TO CLEAN THESE?
♪♪
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> WHAT'S UP, DOLLS?
OH, MY GOD, YOU GUYS.
>> SHOOT.
>> I DON'T CARE
WHAT PEOPLES' PERSONAL SPACES
LOOK LIKE,
BUT I AM NOTICING THAT, LIKE,
GARBAGES ARE OVERFLOWING.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT THIS PAN.
IT'S JUST HOPELESS.
>> THERE'S, LIKE, LITTLE POCKETS
OF GARBAGE EVERYWHERE.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE BATHROOM TUB?
>> ANCHAL, I THINK, LEFT IT
REALLY NASTY.
I DON'T WANT
TO BE A MOM HERE,
BUT LET'S ALL, LIKE,
TRY AND WORK TOGETHER.
WE'VE ONLY BEEN HERE
TWO DAYS,
AND LIKE, OUR KITCHEN IS NARCY.
OKAY, SO I GUESS THE FIRST THING
IS JUST, LIKE, MAKE SURE
IN COMMON SPACES,
TO CLEAN UP AFTER YOURSELF.
WHO LIKES TO SHOWER AT NIGHT?
>> I CANNOT SHOWER
IN THE MORNING.
>> WHO LIKES TO SHOWER
IN THE MORNING?
>> LET'S JUST AGREE TO NOT TAKE,
LIKE, AN HOUR IN THE SHOWER.
>> WELL, I'M GONNA JUST
SAY THIS,
BECAUSE I WOULD BE SITTING HERE
LYING TO SAY,
"YEAH, I WILL TAKE
A 20-MINUTE SHOWER,"
BECAUSE I KNOW I DON'T TAKE
20-MINUTE SHOWERS.
>> I TAKE AN HOUR SHOWER
AT HOME,
BUT THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE
LIVING HERE.
YOU CAN'T JUST--YOU KNOW?
>> I'M TELLING YOU.
I DON'T CARE WHERE I'M AT.
THAT'S JUST ME.
THAT'S JUST WHAT I DO.
AS MUCH AS I TRY TO RUSH,
I STILL TAKE A LONG SHOWER.
>> YOU'RE TELLING US
YOU WON'T CHANGE.
>> THAT'S JUST MONIQUE.
THAT'S JUST WHAT I DO,
SO HEY, SORRY.
>> THIS GIRL
IS SO UNCOOPERATIVE,
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> RIGHT NOW MONIQUE--
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO COMPROMISE,
AND I DON'T--I DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> JUST TRY AND BE--JUST TRY
AND DO WHATEVER YOU HAVE TO DO
WHILE BEING RESPECTFUL
OF ALL OF US.
>> I DON'T DO THAT.
I HAVE A CERTAIN TYPE OF STEPS
THAT I HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
>> MONIQUE IS CUCKOO.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
HER.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> HEY!
>> (cheering)
>> WHOO!
>> ALL RIGHT, READ IT.
>> OKAY, IT SAYS, "TYRA MAIL.
PEOPLE THINK MODELS ARE STUPID,
ANOREXIC, DRUG-ADDICTED BITCHES.
ARE YOU?"
>> NO!
>> YES.
>> I DON'T GET IT.
>> WHAT?
I'M, LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL IS THIS?"
>> WELL, I THINK THAT MEANS
WE'RE DOING A SHOOT TOMORROW.
>> WE'RE NOT ANOREXIC,
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
STOPPED EATING.
♪♪
>> HELLO!
>> (cheering)
>> (French accent)
WHERE IS THE PHOTOGRAPHER?
>> (laughing)
>> WHO ARE THESE YOUNG BITCHES?
(record needle scratches)
>> I AM THE ONLY SUPERMODEL
IN THE WORLD,
AND I AM ALMOST 35,
AND I DO NOT LIKE YOUNG BITCHES!
>> TYRA HAS COMPLETELY
GONE OFF THE DEEP END
OR SKIPPED SOME MEDS
OR SOMETHING.
>> I AM THE QUEEN!
I AM THE QUEEN!
WHAT?
WHERE IS MY WIND?
>> YEAH, WE'RE GONNA GET THE--
>> RON, WHERE IS MY WIND?!
>> WHAT? WHAT? WHAT? WHAT?
I'VE TOLD YOU,
THIS WOMAN NEEDS WIND
CONSTANTLY.
GIRLS, HELP ME BLOW.
>> I NEED WIND.
>> WE NEED THE WIND.
>> YOU ARE NOT BEAUTIFUL
LIKE ME!
GET OFF ME.
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I AM NOT RETURNING TO THE SET
UNTIL ALL OF THESE
LITTLE PREPUBESCENT BITCHES
ARE GONE!
(screams)
>> OH, NO.
>> (shrieking)
>> LOOK WHO IT IS!
>> (cheering)
>> THAT WASN'T
THE REAL TYRA BANKS.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE
PROBABLY THINK THAT
THAT'S HOW TYRA ACTS
ON A DAILY BASIS.
YOU KNOW, SHE WAS KIND OF
PORTRAYING A MODEL STEREOTYPE--
CRAZY DIVA, RIGHT?
>> MM-HMM.
>> WELL, TODAY WE'RE GONNA DO
THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL SHOOT
WE'VE EVER DONE
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> TODAY WE'RE GONNA DO
THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL SHOOT
WE'VE EVER DONE
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
TODAY WE'RE DOING
MODEL STEREOTYPES.
AND THIS IS GONNA BE
A REALLY TOUGH SHOOT.
SO, A.J., YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THE MODEL WORKING
THE CASTING COUCH.
AMANDA--ANOREXIC MODEL.
CARIDEE--THE DUMB BLONDE.
ALL RIGHT, BROOKE--
THE BACKSTABBING BITCH.
CHRISTIAN,
YOU'RE GONNA BE A MODEL
TURNED ACTRESS.
EUGENA--THE BLACK GIRL
THAT THE INDUSTRY IS TRYING
TO TURN INTO A WHITE GIRL.
>> OOH.
>> MEGAN--THE DIVA
WITH A LAPDOG.
MICHELLE, YOU'RE GONNA BE
THE BULIMIA MODEL.
>> OH, NICE.
>> ALL RIGHT?
JAEDA--
THE PLASTIC SURGERY VICTIM.
MEGG, YOU'RE GONNA BE A BIT
OF THE DRUNK, DRUG-ADDICT MODEL.
ANCHAL--THE NARCISSIST, OKAY?
AND, MONIQUE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE
THROWING A CELL PHONE
AT YOUR ASSISTANT.
>> I THINK YOU KNOW THAT ROLE
PRETTY WELL.
>> MELROSE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE THE MODEL
THAT'S NOT GONNA WAKE UP
FOR LESS THAN $10,000 A DAY.
>> YOU READ ME RIGHT, BABY.
>> NOW I UNDERSTAND
YOU WON A CHALLENGE.
SO TODAY, YOU GET TO BE
A DIVA FOR THE DAY.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A PERSONAL ASSISTANT.
YOU'RE GONNA GET SOME
DIVA PAMPERING OF YOUR OWN,
LIKE A LITTLE MASSAGE.
>> THANK GOD.
THANK YOU.
>> I HAD TO GET PHOTOGRAPHERS
THAT SHOOT AMAZING WORK.
>> (cheering)
>> HOW'S IT GOING, GUYS?
SO THIS IS DON,
AND THIS IS BRONSON.
THEY ACTUALLY JUST FLEW IN
FROM EUROPE.
AND THESE ARE YOUR VICTIMS
TODAY, ALL RIGHT?
>> LET'S DO IT.
YOU GUYS READY?
YEAH
SO LETS PILE UP IN TO HAIR AND
MAKEUP
AND LETS GO
♪♪
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> GOOD. HOW ARE YOU?
>> SO I WANNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO LINDSAY, WHO'S GONNA BE YOUR
PERSONAL ASSISTANT FOR THE DAY.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> NOW BE THE DIVA FOR THE DAY.
>> YES.
>> HAVE FUN. ENJOY YOUR DAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU WANT COFFEE?
>> JUST A LITTLE MORE HOT WATER.
>> HOT WATER? GOTCHA.
>> THANKS.
>> BE RIGHT BACK.
>> YOU READY?
>> I'M READY.
>> OKAY, WE ALREADY SHOT
YOUR CELL PHONE.
>> OKAY.
>> SO PRETEND LIKE YOU'RE
THROWING IT AT YOUR ASSISTANT,
AND WE'LL ADD IT TO YOUR PHOTO
LATER.
>> OKAY. READY?
♪♪
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, MONIQUE?
YOU GOTTA GIVE ME
SOME VARIETY THERE,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S JUST
2-DIMENSIONAL.
COME ON, MONIQUE.
IT'S STILL FEELING POSE-Y.
>> IT'S, LIKE, FRUSTRATING ME
>> GOOD. I WANNA GET YOU MAD.
MONIQUE WAS JUST
NOT RISING TO THE OCCASION.
GET MAD AT ME IF YOU HAVE TO.
>> (screams)
>> GIVE IT TO ME!
>> SHUT UP!
>> BITCH! DUMB-ASS!
>> (screams)
I'M FALLING BACKWARDS.
>> THIS IS YOUR LAST SHOT.
>> I DON'T KNOW, IT'S KIND OF,
LIKE, A HARD THING FOR ME.
IT'S DEFINITELY SOME
ACTING SKILLS I NEED TO WORK ON.
>> WOW.
THIS IS THE STUFF
I LEARNED IN, UM...
>> SCHOOL?
>> YES.
>> YES. THAT'S GOOD.
GENIUS.
THAT'S NICE.
>> A LITTLE TOO LUCILLE BALL
AND ZANY.
>> THE LAST ONE. PERFECT.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> MEGG,
I NEED YOU TO GIVE ME
THAT KIND OF STRUNG-OUT LOOK.
>> MY STEREOTYPE WAS A DRUNK,
DRUG-ADDICT CHICK.
>> THINK GIA.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY A STEREOTYPE,
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S TRUE
ALL THE TIME.
>> RIGHT NOW YOU'RE HUNCHED
SO OVER, YOU JUST LOOK LIKE
A BIG BLOB.
THAT WAS IT.
YOU'VE GOTTA LOSE THAT GUM,
THOUGH, BEFORE WE SHOOT.
>> I BROUGHT IT BECAUSE
WHITE GIRLS SMACK GUM.
>> OH, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
GET HER ON SET.
>> MY STEREOTYPE IS BLACK GIRLS
WHO GET IN THE INDUSTRY
AND THEY WANNA BE WHITE.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE BARBIE.
OH, I LOVE THAT. I LOVE THAT.
>> I THINK THEY REALLY SHOULD
PORTRAY AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AS THE WAY THEY ARE, YOU KNOW,
IN EVERYDAY LIFE,
AND THEY NEVER DO.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
STAY LIKE THAT. STAY LIKE THAT.
>> OH, I LOVE THAT.
LOOK AT THAT GENIUS WORK.
DO YOU KNOW WHO
YOUR EXTRA IS TODAY?
>> UNH-UNH.
>> YOU'RE ACTUALLY POSING
WITH TYRA BANKS.
>> REALLY? OH, WOW.
>> I LOVE THE BODY LANGUAGE.
I LOVE THE ARCH.
I LOVE IT.
LOOK AT TYRA. YES.
AND THEN GIVE ME A LITTLE,
"COME ON, BOYS."
>> YEAH. THAT'S STRONG.
THAT'S POWERFUL.
>> I LOVE YOUR EXPRESSION
AT THE END.
AND, TYRA,
YOU DIDN'T DO A BAD JOB EITHER.
A NARCISSIST LOVES HERSELF.
YOU LEAN BACK--YOU ALMOST, LIKE,
OH, YOU CATCH A REFLECTION
OF YOURSELF.
>> I HAVE TO BE, LIKE,
"YEAH, IT'S ALL ABOUT ME."
>> WORK IT.
CHECK YOURSELF OUT.
I WANT YOU SO INTO THIS--
DRIPPING ON THE FLOOR SEXY.
>> WHICH WAS REALLY HARD
SINCE I REALLY NEVER
THINK I'M BEAUTIFUL.
>> LAST FRAME.
GOOD.
REMEMBER, I WANT YOU TO DO YOU.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
THE TYRA BANKS.
>> UH-HUH.
>> OKAY.
CHRISTIAN LOVES TYRA.
SHE EVEN SAID TO US
SHE CAN DO THE TYRA BANKS POSE.
THAT'S GREAT TO LOOK UP
TO SOMEBODY AS AN INSPIRATION--
CHRISTIAN NEEDS TO FIND
HER OWN IMAGE.
>> ACTION.
>> LET'S SEE THAT EMOTION NOW.
YOU'RE CRAZY ABOUT THIS.
COME ON. LET ME SEE IT.
COME ON. COME ON.
>> THE THING THAT FRUSTRATED ME
ABOUT CHRISTIAN--
SHE GAVE ME THE SAME POSE
SHOT AFTER SHOT AFTER SHOT.
>> THAT WAS YOUR LAST SHOT.
>> FROM CASTING TO NOW,
I THINK CHRISTIAN'S
GIVEN ME THE SAME THING--
BROKE DOWN TYRA BANKS.
OBVIOUSLY, SHE'S PUSHING HER
DOWN THE STAIRS.
>> MY ROLE TODAY
WAS THE "BACKSTABBING BITCH"...
>> (screams)
>> I LIKE IT.
>> WHICH IS
MY COMPLETE POLAR OPPOSITE.
>> YES. THAT'S IT.
>> IT WAS FUN TO GET TO PLAY
A BITCH FOR A DAY.
>> OKAY. THAT'S IT.
>> YOU NEED THIS JOB.
THIS IS GONNA MAKE YOUR CAREER.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
A.J. WAS COMPLETELY UNINHIBITED
AND LOOKED LIKE A MODEL.
>> THAT'S THE ONE.
>> YES. I LOVE THAT.
KEEP THAT ANGER UP.
AND YOU'RE CAUGHT.
THAT WAS YOUR LAST FRAME.
IT WAS BELIEVABLE.
CAN WE THROW HER IN THERE?
JAEDA,
YOU ARE THE SURGERY VICTIM.
YOU'RE ALL ABOUT
WANTING TO BE PERFECT.
THINK ABOUT PERFECTION.
WHAT SURGERY ARE YOU DOING NEXT?
YOU'RE GETTING YOUR FACE PULLED.
YOU'VE HAD YOUR CHEST DONE.
I NEED YOU
TO REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING, JAEDA?
>> AND IT'S READING
ON YOUR FACE.
I UNDERSTAND THE BODY POSITION
WAS A BIT STATIC,
BUT JAEDA JUST GAVE ME ONE FACE.
THAT WAS YOUR LAST FRAME.
BE WARM
>> DON'T TOUCH ME.
IT'S COLD.
>> A YEAR AGO,
IF YOU WOULD HAVE TALKED TO ME,
I WAS TOTALLY PESSIMISTIC
ABOUT MODELING.
IN THE BEGINNING,
AMANDA WAS A LOT MORE INTO IT,
AND I WAS JUST KIND OF, LIKE,
"OH, FINE, I'LL GO WITH YOU
FOR THE WHOLE TWIN THING."
BUT NOW I'M A LOT MORE INTO IT
AS WELL.
>> YOU WIPE WITH ONE HAND
YOUR FACE, AND YOUR OTHER ONE
IS, LIKE, "GET OUT."
THAT'S NICE.
>> OH, I LOVE THAT.
>> HEAD UP.
>> YEAH. I LOVE IT.
HEY, MICHELLE,
IT LOOKS REALLY GOOD.
THIS IS DISTURBINGLY AMAZING.
OKAY, GENIUS, LAST FRAME.
YOU LOOK LIKE A REAL
EDITORIAL FASHION MODEL,
WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, GREAT.
>> HIGH FIVE.
>> AH--HELL NO.
>> WAIT. HIGH FIVE.
DON'T LEAVE ME HANGIN'!
>> NOW, AMANDA,
YOU'RE MEASURING YOURSELF,
VERY, LIKE...
STRAIGHT UP. NO.
STRAIGHT UP LIKE A MANNEQUIN.
TALL AND, LIKE, ERECT.
TUCK YOUR HIPS UNDER NOW.
AMANDA DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
HOW TO USE HER BODY.
RIGHT NOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS THIS, AND IT'S BORING.
I NEED... UH!
THERE YOU GO.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO SPEND
A LITTLE MIRROR TIME.
>> OKAY,
GOT THE GIRL READY FOR MELROSE.
>> MELROSE WON HER CHALLENGE.
SHE HAD A PERSONAL ASSISTANT,
HAD A MASSAGE.
AND I THINK A BIT OF THAT
WENT TO MELROSE'S HEAD.
I WAS WAITING FOR HER
FOR ABOUT TEN MINUTES.
CAN SOMEBODY FIND MELROSE?
>> YEAH. BRING HER OUT.
>> IT JUST LOOKS
REALLY CROOKED TO ME.
>> I THINK YOU'RE OVERLOOKING--
YOU'RE STARING AT IT TOO LONG.
NO, REALLY, STOP IT.
>> GETTING THE MASSAGE
WITH MY MAKEUP ON
REALLY DELAYED ME,
AND SO I HAD TO
GET MY MAKEUP REDONE.
>> SHOULD YOU BE THE NARCISSIST?
>> NO.
>> OKAY.
IT'S FINE. YOU'RE CRAZY.
>> I WANT EVERYTHING
TO BE PERFECT
TO WALK INTO THE SHOOT.
>> OKAY, MELROSE.
WHAT'S THE ISSUE?
I'VE BEEN WAITING HERE.
>> OH, HONEY, I'VE BEEN READY
FOR, LIKE, SIX HOURS,
BUT THEN I GOT MY MASSAGE
WITH MY MAKEUP ON,
AND THEN IT CAME OFF,
SO THEY HAD TO FIX IT.
>> REALLY,
THE ATTITUDE RIGHT NOW--
JUST LISTEN.
DON'T SLOW UP THE SHOOTS.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S JUMP IN BED.
>> I'M SO SORRY, YOU KNOW,
AND THEN I JUST KIND OF--
I DIDN'T WANNA BREAK DOWN
AND CRY,
SO I JUST SHUT MYSELF OFF.
>> PEOPLE ARE THROWING MONEY
AT YOU ALL THE TIME.
HOW DARE THIS GUY COME AT YOU
WITH $9,999?
WANT YOU TO BE LIKE,
"OH! PLEASE, GET OUT."
>> WAS THAT HORRIFIED,
OR IS THAT BAD ACTING?
>> IT'S BAD ACTING.
>> YEAH. THANK YOU.
CAN YOU GIVE ME HORRIFIED?
>> AHH!
>> THAT'S BAD ACTING.
I NEED SOMEBODY TO GIVE ME
A CERTAIN SENSE
OF VULNERABILITY,
AND MELROSE WOULD NOT GO THERE.
I WANT YOU TO THINK OF SOMETHING
THAT ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIES YOU.
LET YOURSELF GO.
LET--OPEN THAT DOOR.
YOU'RE ACTING.
LAST FRAME.
THAT'S BAD ACTING.
>> EVERYONE'S DISAPPOINTED
IN ME.
I CAN FEEL
THE WHOLE ROOM IS DISAPPOINTED.
>> I FEEL, AT THIS POINT,
THAT I AM GOING
FROM FEELING LIKE I'M THE BEST
TO FEELING LIKE I'M THE WORST.
(crying)
>> WHOO! TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL HAVE
YOUR FIRST MEETING
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 12 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
ALRIGHT LADIES WE GOT TO GET IT
TOGETHER.
>> I THINK THAT PERFORMANCE-WISE
I STRUGGLED TODAY.
I DON'T THINK
THAT'S REALLY WHO I AM,
AND I GOT A BIG KICK IN THE ASS.
♪♪
>> SO, LADIES, HOW DOES IT FEEL
TO BE IN THIS JUDGING ROOM
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME?
>> CRAZY.
>> UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS WILL BE ONE OF YOU GIRLS'
LAST TIME IN THIS ROOM.
BUT THAT'S A WHILE AWAY,
SO WERE NOT GOING TO CONCENTRATE
ON THAT
WHAT WERE'RE GOING CONCENTRATE
ON
RIGHT NOW ARE THE AMAZING PRIZES
AND THE PRIZES
ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THIS CYCLE.
>> OOH.
>> THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT.
I WAS WITH ELITE MODELS
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE NEXT PRIZE IS A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE--
>> WOW.
>> AND A 6-PAGE EDITORIAL SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE AS WELL.
>> WOW.
>> WHEN I WAS 15 YEARS OLD
IN THE 11th GRADE,
I REMEMBER BOOKING
"SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
AND IT WAS THE VERY FIRST
NATIONAL, BIG MAGAZINE
THAT I'D EVER SHOT FOR.
I REMEMBER THE PHOTO SHOOT--
ONE OF THE SHOTS WAS ME
ON THIS PINK SCOOTER,
AND I THOUGHT I WAS FLY.
AND THE LAST
IS ONE THAT WE KNOW VERY WELL,
AND THAT'S A CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS
WORTH $100,000.
SO NOW IT IS TIME
TO MEET YOUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST
IS NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER.
THE NEXT JUDGE IS RUNWAY COACH
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
AND FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND,
MISS TWIGGY.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE WHICH OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
SO THIS WEEK
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO EVOKE
MODEL STEREOTYPES!
AND, MEGAN, YOU ARE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, MEGAN,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WELL, MEGAN, YOU COMPLETELY
OWN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S REALLY A GREAT FIRST SHOT.
>> CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP?
>> CLOSE-UP ISN'T SO GREAT.
>> (laughs)
THE LIGHT HAS CAUGHT YOUR BACK
EYE
BUT NOT YOUR FRONT EYE.
>> YOU CAN LEARN TO DO THAT
AT HOME IN THE MIRROR,ACTUALLY
OKAY
WHEN YOU GO STRAIGHT UP
LIKE THIS,
YOU GET A LITTLE PIGGY.
>> OH. YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> YEAH.
SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN YOU GO UP,
IT'S MORE TO THE SIDE.
>> OKAY.
>> UP NEXT IS MONIQUE,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
(laughs)
>> WHY COULDN'T A WHITE GIRL
THROW THE PHONE?
>> THE PROBLEM I HAVE WITH THIS
PHOTO
I MEAN
I LOOK AT THE LADY
IN THE SUIT,
AND YOU SHOULD HAVE BEEN'
MUCH MORE IN THE FOREFRONT
FOR ME.
>> I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED
TO SEE A LITTLE MORE ANGER.
>> UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS LOOKS JUST CRAZY.
>> OH, YOU GAVE ANGER,
BUT YOU GAVE...
(growls)
YOU GOTTA REMEMBER THAT THE FACE
HAS TO BE ATTRACTIVE.
THIS IS THE MONEY.
OKAY?
GO BACK OVER THERE.
CARIDEE.
>> WELL, YOU REALLY WENT FOR IT
WITH THE FINGER IN THE MOUTH
AND EVERYTHING, HUH?
>> CARIDEE,
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I WAS VERY PROUD OF YOU.
YOU GAVE STUPID.
YOU GAVE IDIOT.
YOU GAVE CLUELESS.
YOU GAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT TYPES
OF DUMB.
SO DON'T YOU GUYS LIKE THAT?
LIKE, "I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO TAKE THE CAP OFF.
CAN YOU HELP ME TAKE IT OFF?"
>> SURE. LET ME SHOW YOU.
>> OH, MY GOSH. YOU'RE SO SMART.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO CONCENTRATE ON
IS--YOU ALREADY HAVE
THE PERSONALITY.
>> UH-HUH.
>> SOME OF THE OTHER GIRLS,
THEY HAVE THE MODEL THING DOWN,
BUT THEY'RE JUST
DEAD PERSONALITY.
>> OKAY.
>> SO, YOURS IS THE OPPOSITE.
>> IT'S ALMOST PULLING BACK
A LITTLE AND FOCUSING ON THE...
>> OKAY.
>> THE BEAUTY.
>> THANK YOU.
UP NEXT--ANCHAL.
ALL RIGHT, ANCHAL,
SO WHY DON'T YOU
TAKE DOWN YOUR HAIR?
YOU'RE SO MUCH MORE MODEL-Y NOW.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
WOMEN I'VE SEEN IN A LONG TIME,
BUT IT'S THE TYPE OF BEAUTY
THAT ALMOST IS TOO PRETTY.
SO, YOU HAVE TO FIGHT
AGAINST YOUR BEAUTY
SO THAT YOU'RE NOT MISS WORLD,
BUT THAT YOU'RE MISS TOP MODEL.
SHE IS A NARCISSISTIC MODEL
THAT HAS JUST--
HER FACE IN ALL THE MIRRORS.
WELL, ANCHAL,
I REMEMBER YOU WALKED
INTO CASTING WITH BLUE CONTACTS
IN YOUR EYES.
>> IN INDIA, THEY DO BELIEVE
THAT LIGHTER EYES ARE PRETTIER.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL
LOOKING AT YOURSELF
WITH DARK EYES IN THAT PHOTO?
>> IT MAKES ME FEEL PRETTY.
>> IT DOES? WHY IS THAT?
>> BECAUSE IN A WAY I THINK
I WAS HIDING BEHIND THEM.
I'M GLAD.
I'M CRYING AGAIN.
DAMN.
>> IT'S OKAY.
NIGEL, WITH YOU BEING INDIAN,
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU ARE BEAUTIFUL
THE WAY YOU ARE.
WE ARE ALL UNIQUE
IN OUR OWN WAYS,
AND IT'S THAT UNIQUENESS
THAT MAKES PEOPLE BEAUTIFUL.
>> ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, ANCHAL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MEGG.
I DO THINK
THIS IS A LOVELY DRESS
TO GO TO, LIKE, A LUNCHEON.
AND YOUR HAIR MEGG
WHAT'S THIS, WHAT IS GOING ON
YOU DON'T LOOK LIKE A MODEL
THIS IS, LIKE, TOO WIDE HERE.
WE NEED TO SEE MORE SKIN HERE.
AND THIS IS TOO MUCH
GOIN' ON HERE.
>> WHOA!
>> THERE'S A MODEL
RIGHT NOW.
>> SHE LOOKS BUSTED,
BUT A GREAT BUSTED.
>> I WAS TRYING TO LOOK
ALL STRUNG OUT.
>> GIRL, GUESS WHAT?
I DON'T THINK YOU DID A BAD JOB.
>> THIS SHOT DOES NOT BOTHER ME.
BUT YOUR FILM, MEGG,
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
TO YOUR FACE ON FILM
WHERE IT JUST GETS FLAT.
>> FOR THE PHOTOGRAPH,
WE'VE GOT TO SEE YOUR EYES.
>> OKAY, GIVE ME A MODEL FACE.
>> LOOK HOW--
THAT IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
IF YOU CONTINUE AFTER TODAY,
AND YOU AREN'T CONSCIOUS
OF THAT MODEL THING,
I GUARANTEE YOU
YOU WILL GO HOME.
>> OKAY.
>> UP NEXT--AMANDA.
THAT'S A GREAT SHOT
I LIKE IT ALOT
>> SHE'S JUST CAPTURED THE MOOD
OF WHAT SHE'S BEEN ASKED TO DO.
>> THE FACE IS GREAT, TOO.
IT GIVES A BIT OF--
SHE'S A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT HER WEIGHT.
>> THIS WAS THE ONLY SHOT
THAT WORKED,
AND IT'S INTERESTING,
BECAUSE BETWEEN YOU
AND YOUR SISTER,
THIS IS YOUR TRUE, TRUE DREAM.
I KNOW THAT YOU WANT THIS,
AND I THINK THAT YOU PROBABLY
HAVE MORE ABILITY THAN SOME
OF THE OTHER GIRLS BEHIND YOU,
BUT I FEEL LIKE YOU GOT NERVOUS.
WERE YOU NERVOUS?
>> YEAH.
EVERYONE WAS WATCHING MINE.
>> SO YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
WHEN EVERYBODY'S WATCHING YOU?
TURN IT INTO A PERFORMANCE.
YOU'RE ALL WATCHING ME
"LET ME SHOW YOU HOW AMAZING
I AM."
>> THERE ARE ALWAYS
EXTRA BODIES.
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S NOT JUST YOU
AND THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> THANKS.
>> ALL RIGHTY.
UP NEXT IS MICHELLE.
SO, MICHELLE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOURS WAS, I THINK,
THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL
IN THE BUNCH.
>> OH.
>> IT IS A GOOD SHOT,
BUT IT'S A SCARY SHOT.
BUT THAT MEANS YOU GOT IT.
>> YOU REALLY WENT FOR IT.
THIS IS WHAT
THIS WHOLE EXERCISE WAS ABOUT.
PUTTING THAT ACTING
INTO IT, TOO.
YOU GOT AN EMOTION OUT OF US.
>> ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
>> NEXT IS MELROSE.
SO, MELROSE, YOU ACTUALLY WERE
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
SO CONGRATULATIONS TO THAT.
ALL RIGHT, MELROSE,
I THINK THE BLAZER MAKES YOU
LOOK LIKE, "I USED TO MODEL,
AND I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
HOW TO POSE TODAY."
BLAZER OFF.
ALSO, PUT YOUR HAIR
IN A PONYTAIL.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> OH, WHAT A DIFFERENCE.
I SWEAR MELROSE YOU SHAVED OFF
8 YEARS
ALL RIGHT.
SO, MELROSE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU PERHAPS COULD SHOW
A LITTLE BIT MORE EMOTION.
WHAT WORRIES ME
IN A SHOT LIKE THIS IS THAT
YOU PHOTOGRAPHED LOOKING OLD,
AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S WITH RETOUCHING.
>> JAY SAYS
YOU WERE VERY ARGUMENTATIVE,
YOU WERE LATE FOR THE SHOOT,
AND YOU WERE THE WORST
OF THE DAY.
MELROSE EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW
MUCH I HATE GIRLS WHO ARE LATE
TO MY SET.
GENASHA
THE BIG PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS
THAT
YOU'RE A LITTLE LATE
WHICH IS NEVER A GOOD THING
>> I APOLOGIZE,
AND IT WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
SO BROOKE WAS THE JEALOUS GIRL
THROWING THE OTHER BLONDE
DOWN THE STAIRS.
>> YOU HAVE SUCH A PRETTY,
DELICATE FACE,
AND IN THIS SHOT I'VE LOST THAT.
>> BROOKE IN YOUR FILM
YOU WERE VERY SIMILIAR TO
MONIQUE
THINKING THAT ANGER
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE AN UGLY,
PRETTY FACE.
>> BASICALLY,
YOU NEED TO PRACTICE.
ONE THING WE DON'T HAVE
IS A LOT OF TIME.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
UP NEXT IS EUGENA.
>> IT LOOKS GREAT.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT SHOT.
>> FOR ME--
'CAUSE YOU'VE GOT A GREAT FACE,
AND THAT DIDN'T COME ACROSS
IN THAT PHOTOGRAPH TO ME.
IT JUST KIND OF WENT IN TO
BLANDNESS FOR ME
>> I WAS SO FRUSTRATED WITH YOU,
BECAUSE TO ME, YOU'RE ONE
OF THE STRONGEST FACES HERE.
SO TO SEE YOU JUST KIND OF
SITTING ON IT,
IT'S LIKE, "COME ON."
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS A.J.
>> LIKE, I USUALLY CAN--
WHEN A GIRL COMES UP,
I CAN, LIKE, FEEL THEIR DESIRE,
AND WITH YOU I DON'T FEEL THAT.
WHY DO YOU THINK I'M FEELING
THAT?
>> LOW CONFIDENCE.
I DON'T LOOK
LIKE THE OTHER GIRLS.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT THING
GOIN' ON.
>> SO TENS OF THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
TRIED OUT FOR IT,
YOU MANAGED TO MAKE IT
DOWN TO THE FINAL FEW...
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY.
>> AND THAT, FOR SOME REASON,
BREEDS INSECURITY?
>> YOUR MODEL STEREOTYPE
WAS ON THE CASTING COUCH.
>> LOOK AT THAT FACE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A PRETTY
FACE OR NOT?
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> WELL, I'VE GOT NEWS FOR YOU--
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE BEST
FACES I'VE SEEN SO FAR
IN ANY OF THE PICTURES.
>> I'M TRYING TO FIND YOUR NECK
HIDDEN BEHIND THAT COLLAR.
>> YEAH.
THEY KEPT PUSHING IT UP, AND...
>> I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE VERY FULL OF EXCUSES.
IT IS NOT THE COLLAR.
LOOK, I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
AN EXAMPLE.
THAT'S COVERING MY NECK,
BUT LOOK AT ME.
YOU SEE MY ENERGY?
IT'S COVERING MY NECK STILL,
BUT DO YOU FEEL THE DIFFERENCE?
>> YEAH, I DO.
>> ALL RIGHT, A.J.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
>> UP NEXT IS CHRISTIAN.
>> HOW IS EVERYBODY?
>> ALL RIGHT, CHRISTIAN.
WHAT'S GOIN' ON WITH YOUR HAIR?
>> IT'S NOT MODEL.
>> I WAS JUST TRYING NOT
TO PULL MY HAIR BACK SO MUCH
'CAUSE IT'S GETTING DAMAGED.
>> THAT'S JUST WEIRD
THAT YOU'D MAKE THAT DECISION,
LIKE, WHEN THIS IS THE PLACE
WHERE YOU NEED TO WEAR IT
THE RIGHT WAY
AND RISK SOME SPLIT ENDS.
>> MODELS ARE A LITTLE MORE,
SORT OF, TOO WORN AT THE EDGES.
>> SHE'S TOUCHING MY HAIR.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE'RE GONNA WORK YOU OUT.
WE'RE GONNA DRESS YOU UP.
YEAH, THAT'S MUCH BETTER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT LOOKS SO MUCH BETTER.
>> THE PHOTO
JUST DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
YOU LOOK SO MUCH BETTER IN THE
FLESH
>> I WASN'T SURE IF I WAS
GRASPING THE CONCEPT TOO WELL.
>> IF THEY SAY,
"BE A BAD ACTRESS,"
GO FOR IT AND BE A BAD ACTRESS.
"AHH. AHH. OHH! AHH."
YOU KNOW, OVER THE TOP.
AND JAY SAID HE GOT FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE YOU KEPT DOING
THE SAME SHOT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND IT LOOKED LIKE YOU WERE
CATCHING FLIES WITH YOUR MOUTH.
(makes buzzing sound)
LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS JAEDA.
IS IT CHILLY IN HERE?
>> SO I SHOULD TAKE THIS OFF?
IS THAT A HINT?
>> YOU'RE LOOKING LIKE
THE SUBURBAN MOM RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS HIGH SCHOOL AND MALL.
WE DON'T DO THAT IN FASHION.
NO, NO.
>> ESSENTIALLY,
WE WANNA SEE YOU.
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO BE HIDDEN
BEHIND ALL THAT CLOTHES
>> TA-DA.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO WORK
ON LOOKING--ON JUST--
ON BRINGING OUT YOUR FEMININITY.
>> JAEDA,
IN GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I GOTTA TELL YOU,
EVERYTHING LOOKED LIKE THIS.
>> PROBABLY WOULD HAVE THROWN
A LITTLE MORE FACIAL EXPRESSION,
EVEN IF, LIKE, I WAS IN PAIN.
>> THANKS.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪
THEY'RE HAPPY
IN EACH OTHER'S SUCCESS.
IF YOU DO HAVE A COMPETITIVE
EDGE
IT COULD DESTROY YOU
>> MEGG.
>> ASIDE FROM HER BAD POSTURE,
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN WORK ON.
>> IT IS WORRYING,
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T SEE HER EYES
IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
ONCE SHE OPENS HER EYES,
SHE'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE MOST
PHYSICALLY ATTRACTIVE GIRLS
HERE.
>> I LOVE THAT ANCHAL
IS GETTING CLOSER
TO FEELING BEAUTIFUL.
'CAUSE WE ALL KNOW,
AS PEOPLE OF COLOR,
YOU CAN BE TAUGHT THAT
THAT'S NOT BEAUTIFUL.
AND FOR HER TO LOOK AT HERSELF
AND TO TEAR UP,
AND TO SEE DARK EYES
AND THINK THAT'S BEAUTIFUL--
SHE'S ALREADY WINNING
IN THIS COMPETITION.
CHRISTIAN.
>> SHE'S GOT BEAUTIFUL EYES.
SHE'S GOT LOVELY SKIN TONE.
>> I JUST THINK
SHE'S QUITE BORING.
>> YOU TOOK THE WORDS
OUT OF MY MOUTH.
>> BROOKE.
>> HER PERSONALITY
OUTSIDE OF THIS PHOTO IS--
IT'S--IS GREAT.
IT'S NOT HERE.
>> AS MUCH AS IS IT MEDIOCRE,
IT'S ACTUALLY A LITTLE UGLY.
>> MEGAN.
>> I DON'T LIKE THIS PHOTOGRAPH
VERY MUCH, BUT I LIKE HER.
SHE'S A BIT LIKE KIM.
DO YOU REMEMBER KIM?
SHE'S KIND OF THAT ANDROGYNOUS--
>> MEGAN'S SOFTER THAN KIM,
MORE FEMININE.
>> YES, SHE IS.
>> CARIDEE.
>> TRID-A-LEE-DEE,TRID-A-LEE-DEE
CARIDEE.
>> CARIDEE WHO GOT
ONE OF THE EASIEST PHOTOS.
I MEAN, SHE GOT DUMB BLONDE,
AND I THINK DUMB BLONDE
IS RESTING ON EASY FOR CARIDEE.
>> MONIQUE.
>> I LOVE MONIQUE.
HER WEAKNESS MAY BE BEING AFRAID
TO BE UGLY.
>> WELL, SHE DID A BUNCH
OF SHOTS LIKE THIS...
>> GREAT BODY.
I DO THINK SHE'S GOT SOMETHING.
AND SHE'S VERY INTRESTING
AND VERY BEAUTIFUL
>> MELROSE.
>> SHE DOES LOOK A LITTLE BIT
LONG IN THE TOOTH.
I THINK WE CAN BUST HER UP
AND TRY TO MAKE HER A LITTLE
YOUNG AND FRESH
I THINK IT'S JUST CLEANING HER
FACE
>> I'M JUST SO DISAPPOINTED
IN HER PERFORMANCE ON THE SET,
AND TO BE TALKING BACK
TO MR. JAY, AND FLIPPIN' OUT
AND BLAMING THIS
AND BLAMING THAT.
IT'S LIKE,
"HONEY, THIS IS THE FIRST WEEK.
YOU COULD BE CUT LIKE THAT."
IF YOU'RE A BITCH,
HIDE IT.
(laughter)
>> 13 BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE 12 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE 12 OF YOU THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
MICHELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
CARIDEE.
>> OH.
>> A.J.
MEGAN.
ANCHAL.
>> YAY!
SORRY.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
MEGG?
WHERE ARE YOU?
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME I'M GOING TO
CALL IS
MONIQUE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
AMANDA.
JAEDA.
>> WHOO.
I WAS GETTING SCARED
>> EUGENA.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
BROOKE.
>> I'M GOING TO WORK REAL HARD
THIS WEEK
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WILL MELROSE AND CHRISTIAN
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK HER BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
CHRISTIAN,
YOU WALKED INTO THIS ROOM
AND DIDN'T LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
THE JUDGES ALSO LOOKED
AT YOUR PHOTO AND SAID,
"THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S JUST
NOT POPPING THROUGH."
TWO OF THE JUDGES EVEN SAID,
"SHE'S BORING."
MELROSE, YOUR PHOTO--
YOU HAD ONE OF THE MOST
NOTORIOUS MODEL STEREOTYPES.
AND WE LOOK AT THAT PHOTO,
AND WE, LIKE--WE'RE LIKE,
"SHE HAD ALL OF THAT TO GO ON,
AND SHE DELIVERED THAT?"
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT,
THE ATTITUDE
THAT SHE HAD ON THE SET
IS JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> IT'S A LITTLE TOO LATE
FOR "SORRY," MELROSE.
>> YES.
>> I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS.
AND IF WE CATCH YOU
BEING A DIVA
IN YOUR NEXT PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU'RE GOING HOME.
>> OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> OH, MY GOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OKAY, JUST BREATHE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU LEARNED TODAY?
TELL ME WHAT YOU LEARNED.
>> I LEARNED THAT I CAN DO THIS
IF I PUT MY MIND
IN THE RIGHT SPOT.
>> AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE
WAKING UP FOR A LOT LESS
THAN $10,000 A DAY
FOR A LONG TIME.
>> I'LL WORK FOR, LIKE,
A DOLLAR.
>> OKAY.
>> 50 CENTS.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> COME HERE, CHRISTIAN.
IT'S OKAY.
>> (sobbing)
>> I'M CRUSHED.
I'M NOT GONNA ACT
LIKE I DIDN'T WANT IT,
BECAUSE I DID.
I'M JUST REALLY MAD AT MYSELF.
I MEAN, I'M NOT GONNA QUIT,
BUT IT JUST HURTS
REALLY BAD RIGHT NOW.
I WAS HOPING THEY'D REALLY
GIVE ME A SECOND CHANCE
TO PROVE MYSELF,
BECAUSE I REALLY FEEL
LIKE I COULD HAVE GONE FAR
IN THE COMPETITION.
I THINK I WANTED IT
MORE THAN ANYBODY IN THERE,
AND I REALLY DIDN'T
SEE IT COMING.
♪♪